it safely to their spacesuits we do have
a video that will be an overview of
today's space walk where the duo will
exit the station's Quest airlock to
install an upgraded International Space
Station rollout solar array on the 1A
power channel on the starboard truss of
the station so let's learn a little bit
more about what the crew will do during
today's spacewalk
this video is for the Isis roll out
Solar Ray or a Rosa 1A install Eva Steve
Bowen ev1 with the red stripes egresses
and receives a crew lock bag and puts it
on his body restraint tether
ev2 with white stripes Woody hoberg
egresses with acrylic bag on his body
restraint tether and closes the thermal
cover
ev1 translates up the forward face of
the truss and goes starboard he stops to
configure safety to others
ev2 follows a similar translation path
and goes to the port crew equipment
translation Aid cart to temporarily Stow
his bag and retrieve an articulating
portable foot restraint meanwhile ev1
translates to the irosa carrier stows
his bag and retrieves his pistol grip
tool
ev1 begins preparing irosa for removal
from the carrier first releasing a
restraint bolt on the upper eye Rosa
ev2 relocates the foot restraint and
installs it on the Space Station's
robotic arm
ev2 ingresses the foot restraint and
then the arm will move away from the
Truss
ev1 translates to the lower Rosa and
releases its first restraint pull he
releases both anti-rotation devices back
on the upper irosa and then we'll Stow
them in the crew lock bag
on the robotic arm ev2 is flown over to
access two sets of bolts on the boom end
of the upper irosa
the first two bolts will allow the boom
deployment system rollers to be moved
into place to help with the array
deployment later in the spacewalk
the second two bolts will release two of
four mechanisms that hold the Arosa in
its rolled up configuration
ev1 partially releases the upper eye
roses restraint fold and installs the
first to two handling AIDS called scoops
and prep for removing irisa from the
carrier
the arm flies ev2 over to the hinge end
of the upper eye Rosa and both crew
members work to release the final bolt
holding it to the carrier ev1 installs a
second scoop an ev2 lifts the eye Rosa
off of the carrier
after several Maneuvers on the robotic
arm ev2 will arrive at the 1A mod kit
work site
during these Maneuvers ev1 will pick up
the temporarily stowed bag from the port
cart and reconfigure both Cruise safety
tethers on his way to meet ev2 at the
mod kit
[Music]
both crew will then work to install
irosa onto the 1A mounting bracket
the crew will release the scoops and ev2
will move into position to release the
final bolt holding iroza in its folded
position
once released ev1 will hold our Rosa
closed while ev2 egresses his foot
restraint and gets into position
both crew will then work together to
unfold iroza and secure the right side
onto the mounting bracket
once secured ev2 will drive two hinge
bolts that hold iroza in the unfolded
position
ev2 will then move away from my Rosa to
reconfigure a safety tether on the arm
ev1 Works to drive 8 bolts to fully
secure the irsa to the mounting bracket
foreign both crew will then work to
electrically connect the new iroza to
the ISS power system
they'll first attach four connectors to
a Rosa then both will move to either
side of the Legacy array to disconnect
the old array and connect a y cable this
will allow power to flow from both the
new irosa and the Legacy array to the
space station power system
at this point ev1 moves into a
deployment viewing position and ev2 will
release the final two bolts restraining
irosa in the undeployed position
iroza will deploy over the next 6 to 10
minutes
during deployment ev1 translates back to
thyrosa carrier to reconfigure the
carrier beams that previously held the
upper irosa
these beams need to be rotated out of
the way to allow access to the lower
Arosa on the second Eva
once deployment is complete ev2 will
release two bolts that allow the erosa
blankets to become tensioned
ev2 then cleans up the mod kit work site
retrieving his crew lock bag and head to
the carrier to help ev1 with the carrier
beams
[Music]
the crew members work together to
release the bolts holding the beams in
place then they will rotate the beams
out of the way and secure them back down
this is the last task in the first DVA
[Music]
both crew will clean up the work site
and translate back to the airlock
they will clean up their tethers on the
way
they will then work to Ingress and begin
repressing the airlock this will finish
the first of two Evas
foreign
that was an overview of what we can
expect during today's space walk
on your screen here on the top right you
see NASA astronaut Frank Rubio
continuing to step through procedures to
get the crew ready to head out of the
airlock later this morning
and towards the lower left of your
screen you see United Arab Emirates
astronaut sultan al-nayadi
he's working alongside Rubio to prepare
to get the simplified aid for Eva rescue
or safer installed
once the safers are installed on both
hoberg and
Bowen the crew will move
through the airlock and start
depressurization procedures
copy Frank zero zero zero nine
getting a good view inside the back side
of the extra vehicular Mobility unit or
emu
those are the spacesuits that the crew
will be wearing during today's spacewalk
they're essentially a mini life support
system and provide all of the
environment protection mobility and
Communications for the crew members
during space walks
and as Rubio and olneyadi continue to
step through those procedures
ahead of getting the crew ready to begin
depressurization we do have some
statistics to go through today for our
spacewalk
today's space walk will be the ninth
Space Walk for NASA astronaut Steve
Bowen
he has a total space walking time of 54
hours and 19 minutes and for NASA
astronaut Woody hoberg this will be his
very first spacewalk
today's spacewalk will be the 264th
spacewalk in support of space station
assembly maintenance and upgrades and
will be the seventh space station
spacewalk this year and this will be the
fifth spacewalk for expedition 69.
Association on one for Step 11 time one
two one four
and we copy Frank
and if you're just joining us this
morning we have two space Walkers
preparing to exit the International
Space Station's Quest airlock to install
a new ISS rollout solar array
those spacewalkers are NASA astronaut
Steve Bowen who you see in the center of
your screen there
is zero zero two two and zero zero two
zero
thank you copy Frank good numbers
and our other spacewalker today is NASA
astronaut Woody hoberg who will be
completing his very first spacewalk
also in
the equipment airlock is NASA astronaut
Frank Rubio as well as
United Arab Emirates astronaut sultan
al-nayadi
they're continuing to step through
procedures with the crew ahead of
getting them into the crew airlock for
the depressurization sequence
back in the International Space Station
flight control room the orbit 2 team is
ready to support today's spacewalk under
the direction of flight director Diane
Daly
station on 147 21 time 1218.
and copy Frank
in addition to flight director Diane
Daly the rest of the orbit 2 team is
supporting here from Mission Control
Houston as well
to her right as the cap
or right at the Capcom console is the
ground IV and that is Canadian space
agency astronaut Jenny Gibbons
she'll serve as the spacewalk
communicator who will talk directly with
the crew during the spacewalk helping
them choreograph timelines and
procedures
and to her right is NASA astronaut Nick
Hague Who is the Capcom you'll hear him
communicating with the crew up until the
point of depressurization this morning
at which point the ground IV will take
over Community communicating with our
space walking Duo
everything continuing to go smoothly
this morning the next major Milestone
that we can look ahead to is the
installation of the simplified aid for
Eva rescue or safers essential actually
this the space jet pack
this is installed as a precautionary
measure in the very unlikely event that
a crew member were to become untethered
from the International Space Station
this jet pack would allow them to get
back to the space station
following safer installation we can look
ahead to depressurization
first the crew will move to the crew
lock section of the quest airlock
and depressurization will occur in a
two-stage fashion
first the crew lock will be taken down
to five pounds per square inch of
pressure
at this point they'll pause
depressurization to do a systems check
and then
and we are seeing on the audio and Rubio
work together to install the safer
uh step eight uh we Ojo go your go to
turn off the hecka it's a just if you
want to turn off Echoes on both EVS
that'd be great
thanks so much
again all neody and Rubio now working
together to install the safer simplified
aid for Eva rescue on NASA astronaut
Steve Bowen's space suit
and Rubio and alnaadi working to get
that safer installed on NASA astronaut
Steve Bowen's spacesuit
for today's space walk Bowen is
designated ev1
and he'll be wearing the spacesuit with
the red stripes which you can see on
your screen there
Woody hoberg will be designated ev2 and
would be wearing an unmarked spacesuit
once both safers are installed the next
Milestone that we can look ahead to is
depressurization and ultimately when the
crew will then exit the International
Space Station's Quest airlock
they'll then work together to install an
upgraded International Space Station
roll out solo array on the 1A power
channel on the starboard truss of the
International Space Station
the iroses were delivered on a SpaceX
Dragon cargo resupply Craft on Monday to
the space station
Rubio and alniadi continuing to get the
safer simplified aid for Eva rescue
installed on NASA astronaut Steve
Bowen's spacesuit
following installation of the safer
Bowen will be moved to the crew airlock
for depress
and Bowen now being moved into the crew
airlock
next up Rubio and alniadi will work
together to get
hoberg's safer installed
and Rubio and al-naadi now going to work
together to get the safer installed on
hoberg's spacesuit
again he'll be designated ev2 and he's
wearing the spacesuit with
the unmarked spacesuit this morning
as Rubio and elnayadi continue to step
through those procedures to get the
safer installed we can take a quick look
ahead at what's to come
following getting the safer installed
both crew will be moved into the airlock
to begin the depressurization process
the depressurization of the airlock is
done in a two-stage process first the
crew lock will be taken down to five
pounds per square inch of pressure
at this point depressurization will be
paused to do a systems check following
this depressurization will resume and
continue all the way down to vacuum
now once vacuum is reached the two space
Rock space Walkers will complete suit
and communication checks before placing
their spacesuit on internal battery
power which will officially Mark the
start of today's space walk
a U.S spacewalk start and end time is
measured from the time the crew places
their space suit on internal battery
power all the way up until the time
repressurization occurs and they're back
inside the crew lock following
completion of their spacewalk
we are expecting today's spacewalk to
last about seven hours
and here in Mission Control Houston NASA
flight director Diane Daly did just pull
the team of flight controllers on
console and everything is looking good
we are go for today's spacewalk
Rubio now going to work to get Bowen
moved into the crew airlock
hoberg rather Boeing currently is in the
crew airlock already
both Bowen and hoberg now in the crew
airlock
once they get situated and everything
looks good we will see the hatch close
and the depressurization process begin
thank you
Penn Station Houston uh when able on one
hey Frank uh just uh we're trying to get
in front of an Los with some ground
commanding there's a couple steps that
you're going to confirm later on we'd
like to do early that's step 76 and 77.
and that was the voice of
America
is closed and node one map is connected
to the Democrat
copy Frank thanks for doing this
and that was the voice of today's Capcom
and NASA astronaut Nick Hague
calling up to Rubio letting him know
that there is a loss of signal coming up
giving them the go to step through a
couple of procedures during that loss
and station Houston on one
no action for you you can acknowledge
with the thumbs up we're going to
command so you go hop mic for the EV
crew
station Houston uh we're with you on one
if you try to transmit last I want to
let you know the crew is going to go hop
my care shortly and also you've got to
go in step 84.
okay next copy uh crew will be hot Mike
and go on step 84 and then just be
advised you're coming in a little bit
weak you're readable
copy all
foreign
IV
and your go to press
and I copy Prime IV go to press thanks
so much
and we did just hear that confirmation
from the ground that the crew is go to
continued depressurization first up
they'll close the hatch which only and
Rubio are working together to do so you
can see on your screen
foreign
and you did see that hatch just get
closed
we are in an expected Handover between
ground stations
so we are not going to expect to have
video of the crew on board the
International Space Station for the next
11 and a half minutes however we do know
that they're going to continue the
depressurization process as they have
the go from the ground to do so
and if you're just joining us this
morning we have two spacewalkers who are
suited up and in the process of
working through depressurization
procedures today they will exit the
station's Quest airlock to install an
upgraded irosa or International Space
Station rollout solar array on the 1A
power channel on the starboard truss of
the International Space Station we do
have an animation to walk us through
what we can expect our space Walkers to
complete today so let's take a quick
look
foreign
[Music]
Steve Bowen ev1 with the red stripes
egress is
there ev2 with white stripes Woody
hoberg egresses with acrylic bag on his
body restraint Heather and closes the
thermal cover
ev1 translates up the forward face of
the truss and goes starboard he stops to
configure safety to others
ev2 follows a similar translation path
and goes to the port crew equipment
translation Aid cart to temporarily
stose bag and retrieve an articulating
portable foot restraint meanwhile ev-1
translates to the irosa carrier stows
his bag and retrieves his pistol grip
tool
ev1 begins preparing irosa for removal
from the carrier first releasing a
restraint bolt on the upper eye Rosa
ev2 relocates the foot restraint and
installs it on the Space Station's
robotic arm
ev2 ingresses the foot restraint and
then the arm will move them away from
the Truss
ev1 translates to the lower Rosa and
releases its first restraint bulb he
releases both anti-rotation devices back
on the upper eye Rosa and then we'll
Stow them in the crew lock bag
[Music]
on the robotic arm ev2 is flown over to
access two sets of bolts on the boom end
of the upper irosa
the first two bolts will allow the boom
deployment system rollers to be moved
into place to help with the array
deployment later in the spacewalk
the second two bolts will release two of
four mechanisms that hold the Arosa in
its rolled up configuration
ev1 partially releases the upper eye
Rosa's restraint bolt and installs the
first of two handling AIDS called scoops
and prep for removing erosa from the
carrier
the arm flies ev2 over to the hinge end
of the upper eye Rosa and both crew
members work to release the final bolt
holding it to the carrier ev1 installs a
second scoop an ev2 lifts the eye Rosa
off of the carrier
foreign
[Music]
Maneuvers on the robotic arm ev2 will
arrive at the 1A mod kit work site
during these Maneuvers ev1 will pick up
the temporarily stowed bag from the port
cart and reconfigure both Cruise safety
tethers on his way to meet ev2 at the
mod kit
[Music]
both crew will then work to install
irosa onto the 1A mounting bracket
the crew will release the scoops and ev2
will move into position to release the
final bolt holding a rose and its folded
position
once released ev1 will hold our Rosa
closed while ev2 egresses his foot
restraint and gets into position
both crew will then work together to
unfold iroza and secure the right side
onto the mounting bracket
once secured ev2 will drive two hinge
bolts that hold ivosa in the unfolded
position
ev2 will then move away from my Rosa to
reconfigure a safety tether on the arm
ev1 Works to drive 8 bolts to fully
secure the irosa to the mounting bracket
both crew will then work to electrically
connect the new irosa to the ISS power
system
they'll first attach four connectors to
our Rosa then both will move to either
side of the Legacy array to disconnect
the old array and connect a white cable
this will allow power to flow from both
the new irosa and the Legacy array to
the space station power system
at this point ev1 moves into a
deployment viewing position and ev2 will
release the final two bolts restraining
iroza in the undeployed position
irosa will deploy over the next 6 to 10
minutes
during deployment ev1 translates back to
diversa carrier to reconfigure the
carrier beams that previously held the
upper irosa
these beams need to be rotated out of
the way to allow access to the lower
irosa on the second Eva
once deployment is complete ev2 will
release two bolts that allow the erosa
blankets to become tensioned
ev2 then cleans up the mod kit worksite
retrieving his crew lock bag and head to
the carrier to help ev1 with the carrier
beams
[Music]
the crew members work together to
release the bolts holding the beams in
place
then they will rotate the beams out of
the way and secure them back down
this is the last task in the first DVA
[Music]
both crew will clean up the work site
and translate back to the airlock they
will clean up their tethers on the way
they will then work to Ingress and begin
repressing the airlock this will finish
the first of two Evas
and that is a high level level overview
of what we can expect from today's
spacewalk
if you're just joining us to NASA
astronauts are currently suited up and
in the crew airlock and are working
their way through depressurization
procedures
today's space walk space Walkers are
NASA astronaut Steve Bowen and today
will be his ninth spacewalk as well as
NASA astronaut Woody hoberg who will be
completing his first spacewalk
Bowen Ann hoberg will venture outside
for a spacewalk expected to last about
seven hours today the focus of which
will be on the starboard truss of the
International Space Station to install
and monitor the deployment of one of the
irosas or ISS rollout solar array
both of which were delivered on a SpaceX
cargo Dragon resupply vehicle on Monday
to the space station
and today's space walk is the 264th in
support of space station assembly
maintenance and upgrades
this is the seventh spacewalk in 2023
and the fifth spacewalk for expedition
69.
as we mentioned it's the ninth space
work spacewalk for Bowen who has a
cumulative space walking time of over 54
hours across eight previous spacewalks
the iro said that the crew will install
today is 60 feet long and 20 feet wide
it Shades a little more than half of the
original or Legacy arrays which are 112
feet long by 39 feet wide
each new irosa produces more than 20
kilowatts of electricity and once all
the iroses are installed it will enable
a 30 percent increase in power
production over the International Space
Station's current arrays
and we are in a loss of signal period as
we have a Handover between satellites
however we are expecting Communications
and video to be back here in less than a
minute
during this loss of signal period the
crew has been stepping through
procedures in order to work through
depressurization of the airlock
this is done in a two-stage process
first the crew lock goes down to five
pounds per square inch of pressure at
which point that depressurization will
be paused to do a systems check
and then following this depression
depressurization will resume to bring it
all the way down to the vacuum
now once that vacuum is reached the two
space Walkers will complete some
additional suit and calm checks before
placing their spacesuit on internal
battery power officially marking the
start of today's spacewalk
and pressure inside of the crew lock is
about 7.27 pounds per square inch again
we'll pause once that pressure reaches 5
pounds per square inch
foreign
station Houston on one we're back with
you boys only
yeah we have your last favorite coffee
boys only thanks
Stephen what are you guys talking you
have about 100 millimeters of mercury to
go
I agree
pressure inside the crew lock now at
6.35 pounds per square inch of pressure
laughs
now less than six pounds per square inch
of pressure inside the crew lock
again once we do reach five pounds per
square inch that depressurization will
be paused to do a systems check
everything's still looking good for
depressurization now at
5.18 pounds per square inch of pressure
inside the crew lock
foreign
the next action is going to be for you
we have about 10 to go
I copy Frank standing bye
forty two breast pump manual valve
closed both of you can expect an alert
home
and copy closed okay next thing we're
going to do is a leak check so you'll
both take your switch display status
until reach our question mark is
displayed hold that for two seconds and
then follow the displayed instructions
don't worry if you want
uv2 and work
and pressure inside the crew lock is now
at five pounds per square inch of
pressure so you did hear those words
about the systems check that are
occurring now
following the system's check
depressurization will resume and
continue all the way down to vacuum
and once facts reach the two space
Walkers will complete some additional
suit and communication checks before
they Place their spacesuit on internal
battery power officially marking the
start of today's spacewalk
and following this the crew will of
course exit the airlock and begin
working to get that irosa installed
complete if you won moving to Eva
that'll be a minute
[Applause]
[Music]
let me know when that's complete
EPA
51 is an Eva
hey how to actuator Eva and forth 20 and
Steve it's my job
what are you going to take the deepest
month man ISO valve to open both of you
can expect an alerts copy
correct spot man as the valve is open
foreign
is also open both of you continue to
monitor your super pressure gauge make
sure that it remains less than five
decimal five again if it ever goes above
five decimal five let us know and we'll
start the defense keep going BBQ coffee
our next action will be at 2 PSI copy I
see it
and those system checks looking good
depressurization is continuing as
expected
pressure inside the crew lock now less
than four pounds per square inch of
pressure
foreign
pressure inside the crew lock now
approaching three pounds per square inch
of pressure
foreign
and we are getting a view back inside of
the equipment lock here where NASA
astronaut Frank Rubio on the left and
United Arab Emirates astronaut Sultan
al-nayadi continue to step through
depressurization procedures with hoberg
and Bowen who are inside the crew lock
pressure inside the crew lock now it
2.68 pounds per square inch of pressure
once vacuum is reached inside the crew
lock the two space Walkers will complete
additional suit and communication checks
before they do Place their spacesuit on
internal battery power which will Mark
the official start of today's spacewalk
a U.S spacewalk start and end time is
measured from the time the crew places
their spacesuit on internal battery
power
123 continuing to 103.
you see two decimal one
now closing in on two pounds per square
inch of pressure inside the
International Space Station's crew lock
okay press pump and ISO valve closed
closed
copy close 40 on the UIA switch
depressed pump power off of speed press
mode power is off
okay guys I will turn you over to Jenny
for your initial tether config and Jenny
you are prime
ready for the config
it's great Jenny I'm in a great con uh
great position to read you the config
starting at the erlock during extender
go
all right we're lucky on your extender I
have my left waist tether gate closed
locked lock on block
the waste other small Hook is on my left
Fury extender
it closed lock on block
to my left ear extender I have my Red
Hook
unlocked
I read real and green reels are both
the red Wheels yellow Hook is gay closed
lock block on black to my green reel
my green reels small tree soap is gate
close locked on my rear wheel
and the green reels anchor hook goes to
spear right place each other
[Music]
foreign
both reels are unlocked I have the
flank hook through my mini workstation
now my left hand side I have
let's go
back so I can actually eventually open
the hash
oh I copy all we are in a good config
thanks so much James and good morning to
you and the orbit 2 team
good morning we are happy to be here
excited to work with all of you
and you are now hearing the voice of
Jenny Gibbons who is the ground IV
y she'll be stepping through procedures
with the crew during today's spacewalk
and that pressure inside the crew lock
now at vacuum the Woody and Steve were
continuing the Deep press here it'll
take a couple of more minutes
uh when the crew lock the PDT is
approximately zero expect an alert tone
BBQ copies
that pressure inside the crew lock is
continuing to approach vacuum it's now
at 0.97 pounds per square inch
fun to watch you guys do this
depending on you this is going to be
good you guys are good
working this is gonna work out really
well
thanks so much you guys did a fantastic
job idea this morning thanks so much for
everything
a pleasure we'll see you in a few hours
everything continuing to go smoothly
this morning
as
NASA astronaut Woody hoberg and Steve
Bowen around
around eight or nine more minutes
to 2.5 PSI
it says watching it go very slowly
sounds good
again everything going smoothly so far
this morning as we anticipate the
spacesuits to be switched over to
battery power here shortly as soon as
those calm checks and system checks are
completed
following this the crew will egress or
exit the the hatch after they open the
thermal cover
ah
and we are continuing to get views
inside the International Space Station
you are seeing NASA astronaut Frank
Rubio who helped to get Bowen and hoberg
suited up and ready to go this morning
all night now floating into screen as
well
Bowen and hoberg are inside the crew
lock which continues to depress now at
.64 pounds per square inch rapidly
approaching vacuum
the goal of today's spacewalk is to
install an upgraded irosa or
International Space Station rollout
solar array on the 1A power channel on
the starboard truss of the space station
today's irosa installation will be the
fifth installed on the space station
thank you
pressure inside the crew lock now at
0.55 pounds per square inch of pressure
and pressure inside the crew lock now at
0.5 pounds per square inch of pressure
Stephen Woody we are at 0.5 PSI you are
go to verify the EV hatch gauge is less
than 0.6 PSI and open the EV hatch
at drill professional 4.
copy zero decimal four you go
all right
patch is open
is
coming close
this Equalization value is closed
captions
and we are hearing that the hatch is
open
pressure inside the crew lock now a
vacuum
both hoberg and Bowen are now going to
work together to egress or exit the
airlock
copy Frank emergency mpev closed now we
are in post depress Woody and Steve on
your dcm's switch power to bat stagger
your switch throws and expect a warning
tone
very easy one power
for the battery
everyone could be sir blank nobody
too good restart blank no bite
we verified you have a functional
display
switch power eb1 and 2 to off off on the
UIA
[Music]
copy check power ev1 and 2 LEDs all four
are off
[Music]
we're LEDs off
copy off
switch display to Pro to verify
functional display
functional EBT display functional
that'd be two functional displays you
can disconnect your scus install your
DCM covers and Stow the scu's in their
pouches
all right if you want to correction eb2
in the pouch
foreign
copy ev1 and ev2 as the user in the
pouches
on the check depressed pump pump many
pump man pump many many many many
many many many
many from
everybody
all right if you want to keep my
thoughts
copy everyone
switch water on
if you want water on
dv2 water on
check DCM blank bite off and at 8 25 a.m
central time this morning the 264th
spacewalk in support of station assembly
maintenance and upgrades has
beguns as desired report all subsequent
changes to MCC
foreign
[Music]
copy both tcvs set to four reports suit
pressure gauge
everyone two EV two four decimal four
copy for decimal two and four decimal
four set your visors as required we have
around 10 minutes till sunrise
two copies
all right
with that Steve you can open the thermal
cover we'll have you Stow the hook on
the stiffener tether Point cinch the
strap and Report Sharpie lines visible
all right
[Music]
foreign
and we are expecting the thermal hatch
cover to open momentarily
and we are seeing that thermal cover
begin to open these is preparing to
egress you can retrieve crew lock bag m
you'll be sewing this on your brt and
handing crew lock bag tea out to Steve
all right granny sounds great all right
[Music]
oh two
three four five six flags visible
Pepe Steve that's a good config egress
the airlock
all right
and we are seeing NASA astronaut Steve
Bowen egress the airlock
he's designated ev1 today and he'll be
wearing that spacesuit with the red
stripe so he's the first out of the
airlock
here
Steve no rush at all but got back to you
when you're ready
Bowen is still inside the airlock Hill
egress here shortly but first he's going
to hand a crew lock crew lock bag to
Steve
okay
it's good
[Music]
easy on the back I'm back
on my brt
and lock
Houston hey Steve awaiting your go to
egress all right I'm gonna get my
other school like
all right you ever go to egress copy go
to eat restaurants
after egress you can both turn on your
hekkas and perform body checks
and next out of the airlock is going to
be NASA astronaut Woody hoberg who is
completing his very first spacewalk this
morning
he'll be wearing the spacesuit with no
stripes on it the unmarked spacesuit and
his designation is ev2
[Applause]
[Music]
once both crew members are out of the
airlock they'll work to
translate to their next location but
first they're going to turn the lights
on on their helmet cameras
uh
so it sounds like a few years in
previous
both crew members now out of the airlock
I'm going to get I'm going to plan to be
asked Steve all right I'm coming back
around the other way sounds great
but I'm in a great spot for Buddy checks
if you want to do them here yeah let's
do them here okay great thank you
Houston's ready to copy buddy checks
confirm your hackers are on
and I see what he's been afraid
the
[Music]
the light with the other one
uh your nbcd is off pivot okay goodbye
handle down
and
whatever
[Applause]
just getting my crew lock bag on yeah
we'll just
[Music]
ready when you are all right let me see
one thing left to check
okay right pretty bright
um your senior TV shows not on yet
okay hit the button oh there it is I'll
see you now okay okay and uh let's see
safer handles down there's these two
tabs up
and I see two green lights
and I see your lights are awesome
all right Steve for you I see too many
workstation tabs on a brt tab all three
up
I see a green wvs light and a green heco
light your lights are on
looking at tools and cutters
put your bag on your brt
and
you're looking good Steve all right
I am and I will need to check your super
handles one two both download thank you
starting off my gloves look good and I
have it dried up
as well
copies good buddy checks good uh glove
checks and dry hops for both of you you
can tend the thermal cover closed and
Steve you'll be translating to the
Anchor hook location I have more words
for you when you're on your way
all right give me one second
I got the camera Steve
all right yeah and Jenny I'll have to uh
hold on fully closing the cover for my
waste better
Debbie just tend to close for now thanks
Woody
Bobby
and Bowen and hoberg completed some
initial checks to ensure everything is
looking good on their suits
they're now going to get that thermal
hatch cover closed
Steve I have a caution for you avoid
contact with the deployed test cable
good read back for you both for around
two minutes to Sunrise
you're looking for the shrc
so S1 shrc
okay
and hoberg is getting the thermal cover
closed
meanwhile Bowen is translating up the
forward face of the Truss
Steve that mile marker is six three zero
zero
six three zero zero thank you
once the thermal cover is closed hoberg
is going to follow a similar translation
path
but he's going to stop at the Port crew
equipment translation Aid cart
and he's going to pick up an
articulating portable foot restraint
this is going to be required for him
later in the spacewalk when he steps
into it on the Canada arm 2. this is
where you'll place your anchor hook it's
the Nader most handrail under the shrc
we're looking for the Nader stanchion
all right neighbors dancing
[Music]
close by or locked red wheel
is unlocked
to my right steering extender
just get close like a walk
[Music]
and the greenhouse between the green and
red dragon heels is gay course level up
anchor hook on handrail 3247 which is
the Zenith handrail just above yours
okay that didn't work
ah
okay what do you talk
they close fireworks if he's turning
back to the airlock
Debbie that is a good load path for
Woody you can give Woody the go to
release his waist tether
would you have a good release your waste
better do you like coffee picking it up
Steve you can now translate to the FSE
work site you'll be dropping your green
hook on S3
handrail 3011 which is made out of the
Port City cart
not that now
copy Steve or Woody excuse me once
that's complete you can close the
thermal cover
I broke up the jam space uh closed
puppy Woody once that's complete you can
translate you are headed to the crew
lock bag storage location on the Port
City cart
all right Johnny I copy thanks
Steve winready I have cautions and a
warning for you
okay goodbye
all right we're doing awesome
warning grapple shafts and curvet
coupling are no touch and cautions no
aggressive movements or quick grabs on
the FSE translate slowly
wait for motion to dampen out before
imparting loads and do not contact the
iroza blankets
and with the thermal cover closed
Holberg is now working to translate to
the Flight Support equipment work site
this is essentially a palette that is
currently holding the iroses
[Music]
I copy your green hook on handrail 3011
zero one one or three zero one one
three zero one one
okay
following this Steve you'll be
translating onto the FSE
via the POA and the crew is running
about 10 minutes ahead of today's
timeline
today's space walk is unique in that
once the International Space Station
roll out array or irosa is installed
cables will need to be mated during an
eclipse portion so this spacewalk is
very carefully choreographed
have to ensure that this timing takes
place as necessary
and you are seeing this view from the
helmet cam of NASA astronaut Woody
hoberg who is completing his first
spacewalk today
he's continuing to translate or move
make his way over to the palette where
the iroses are installed
see the cart Mater handrail
he is currently at the Port Cedar cart
where he's going to temporarily drop off
one of his crew lock bags
and he's also going to pick up an apfr
and articulating portable foot restraint
which will allow him to step into and
ride on the Canada arm 2
. hoberg will be carrying the irosa
while he's on the Canada arm 2 in order
to move it over to be installed
today's solar array will be installed on
the 1A power channel on the starboard
truss of the International Space Station
all right
foreign
seconds to a short Handover
and we are in a brief expected Handover
between satellites but we'll regain
Communications and video with the crew
during their spacewalk here momentarily
foreign
Steve Woody I'm back with you after the
Handover
coffee and I see that small bushing on
the uh Laura Rosa
copy your eyes on the font thanks Steve
Woody you will be picking up the apfr in
with three looks like you're already
there should have an Ingress Aid
and it does
and this view from NASA astronaut Woody
hoberg's helmet cameras he works to pick
up the articulating portable foot
restraint from the port Ceda cart
foreign
[Music]
copy the paddles
Woody this is in line with what we
expect for this apfr
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
copy a tcv of two for Woody
[Music]
negative seven
copy seven
[Music]
adjustable or small goes to zero zero
zero eight
and the integral goes to the upper
paragraph
a firm that's right uh Steve that
handrail should be 13. once that's done
I'll take a glove inspection half check
ing place
and while hoberg Works to secure that
articulating portable foot restraint
after grabbing it from the port Ceda
cart we are going to hear Bowen complete
a glove and hap check
you're headed to the
to the Ingress location
the hap is the helmet absorption pad
and this is checked regularly throughout
the spacewalk along with the gloves just
to assure that everything is performing
as expected
[Music]
[Applause]
with the articulating portable foot
restraint now in hand hoberg is going to
work to install it on the Canada arm 2.
[Music]
copy
Woody I have your next step working with
Frank to GCA to the published apfr
install position
all right James I agree uh Steve do you
need the comp just for one second I'm
going to head over to
R5
from the upper
and Steve can you confirm that you've
picked up the PGT I left the ret on the
bag so that's now in your swing arm and
I need a glove inspection hat check
okay first
and you
we were getting a view there briefly of
the iroses and there we see it again
here in the International Space Station
roll out raise there's two on that
pallet on the very left of your screen
one of them is going to be installed
today and the other will be installed on
June 15th
we're also getting a view of the Canada
arm 2 which hoberg will be utilizing
today when he moves the irosa to the 1A
power Channel
s
rat on here correct
a firm leave the rut on your swing or
leave the rut on the bag and red swap to
the swing arm rest
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
copy and that was a good read back
and also in your frame there you can see
a dragon vehicle that actually brought
up the ISS rollout solar arrays at
Dragon dock to the International Space
Station on Monday
following the docking the ISS rollout
solar arrays were removed from Dragon's
trunk and placed on that pallet that you
just saw there and next our space
Walkers are going to work to remove that
first irosa solar array by removing some
bolts and working through some
procedures to loosen it up before it can
be hand carried by hoberg on the robotic
arm
parameter to go
continue
copy continue
to go
put your needs are published
tend to go continue to publish
and ramping out
okay that is our published position how
is it how's that looking all right
Photon can you please give me five zero
centimeters station Mater
I thought it would be a half a meter
station later in welcome thank you
what's up
that's a good motion
copy a good motion
okay 30 centimeters ago continue
continuing
they're ramping out
okay that is a half a meter station
meter
that is uh GCA complete that's a perfect
position
right coffee just here complete and
bricks are coming on copy breakthrough
and I'll be installing the apsr Woody
were looking for you are going to
install the apfr Woody we're looking for
a clocking of 12.
I'll be clocking 12 and I already
confirmed
good settings
Steve I'm back with you
counterclockwise too
and
um releasing RFI
copy the boat Will Spring out when fully
released and you'll see a white line
indicator expect 18 to 20 turns
hoberg continuing to step through
procedures to get that articulating
portable foot restraint installed on the
Canada arm 2.
this articulating portable foot
restraint or apfr allows him to click
his face walking boots into it so that
he can ride aboard the Canada arm too
he'll be carrying the irosa while he
does so
any apfr is installed in the arm
at 12. talk about the fox six
always block on block good pull twist
test and the pitch knob can be depressed
tubby witty good checks now we'll need
you to perform a safety tether swap to
the arm let me know when your yellow
Hook is on the ssrms tether point and
I'll take your checks
all right sounds good Jimmy
all right
let us do a couple bumps
[Music]
so that we verified it was clear
cubby 27 turns and the bolt is fully
released can you see a white line
indicator
copy you can store your PGT and we are
currently in an expected Handover
between our satellites
we do have communications with the crew
however we do not have video at this
moment but we'll regain it
copy translate to stanchion Bravo
Berg has completed installing the apfr
on the robotic arm
[Music]
together
hi Jenny my yellow hook
gate closed locked block on block for
the ssrms tether Point green Hook is
stowed on mile marker 6360 and that
green reel is unlocked
[Music]
copy Woody that is a good can fake
insert ensure that uh Steve's tether is
clear of your green hook and then you
can work with Frank to get to the
Ingress position
all right let me get eyes on Steve's
tether
it's well clear
and I am in a
great config for apfr Ingress no GCA
needed
okay Woody we are coffee and uh vets are
still on your go for fbfr Ingress got
the great song go for immigrants thank
you so much Woody you need to attach a
waste tether to the Ingress Aid
yep in work camps thanks
thank you
and hoberg has successfully gotten the
articulating portable foot restraint
installed on the Canada arm 2 he's now
going to work to click his boots into
the articulating portable foot restraint
and Ingress it
this will allow him to fly on the Canada
arm too
[Music]
and you are seeing him work to Ingress
that apfr on your screen right there
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
all right so I've got Bravo 2
o'clockwise too
going to R5
and looking for a full release and a
white indicator
good word Steve expects
18 to 20 turns I have written here
all right 18th 21st okay
and Steve I'm gonna look for the con
again when you have a chance
thanks it's so fun I'm ready for trust
back off
all right copies uh we are ready and
breaks are coming off coffee breaks off
would you ensure your check your tools
and tethers are clear we need you to
confirm that
stamps yep fools and Cutters are all
clear
copy I agree you are a go to proceed
Woody we also are hearing that you're
left safer handle might be up we need
you to check both of them
your team was correct
and both safer handles are down
copy both safer handles down on Woody
thank you you guys are doing great on
time
when you are we're gonna bring you first
station forward about 80 centimeters and
then station later uh three meters
um 60 centimeters come on I'm ready for
all of that here we go
than the starting ocean station board
good motion Photon okay good motion
and as you can see on your screen now
hoberg now being moved while in that
articulating portable foot restraint on
the Canada arm
that Canada arm is being operated by
United Arab Emirates astronaut Sultan
al-niadi who is inside the International
Space Station
hoberg is going to be translated to a
better position to help NASA astronaut
Steve Bowen remove some bolts
and an anti-rotation device which will
enable the irosa to be released from the
palette
following this hoberg will hand carry it
while on the Canada arm 2 over to the 1A
work site
okay one meter to go
and this view from NASA astronaut Woody
hoberg's helmet cam as he is on the
Canada arm too looks like he's taking
this opportunity to get some truly out
of this world photography
and ramping out
that looks good for Tom
okay with you just heads up next uh
we're gonna take you to the volt axis
joynercast that'll be two minutes and a
half
ready for that okay guys thanks a lot
set up
Dory 20 turns
the lower Arosa uh with the good White
Band
copy our release I understand R5 on the
lower eye roses released with 20 turns
you should be pretty much at the bolts
for C2 we are going to work on releasing
these anti-rotation devices so you can
attach an adjustable equipment tether
and from your small trash bag to the Ard
tether point
okay
all right
here we are ready when you are for the
journalcast I'm ready for conference
copy
foreign
continuing to be moved on the Canada arm
too
meanwhile Bowen is working with the
pistol grip tool or PGT to release bolts
this is a restraint Bolt
next up he's going to work on releasing
the anti-rotation devices
all of this is
all of this is in preparation for
ultimately removing the International
Space Station rollout solar array from
this carrier this palette that is
temporarily stowed on
[Music]
and as hoberg continues to make his way
over to his first work site the
International Space Station is currently
flying
258 statute miles off the coast of Nova
Scotia over the North Atlantic Ocean
Woody we need you to repower your hecca
.com
oh actually Jenny I just pressed the
power button and I see a green light so
it should be on now yes we just needed
you to power it that's correct it was
knocked off earlier
okay copies
getting a really great view here of
Woody hoberg in the articulating
portable foot restraint
see
it's hard to clockwise too
good read back
yes 10 turns only a reminder these are
not captive so we only want to release
10 turns
only
and in hoberg's hand you can see the PGT
or pistol grip tool this is essentially
the space drill it's going to be
utilized a lot throughout today's space
walk first to remove the irosa from the
palette and then to reinstall it on the
1A power Channel
Papi Thanks James good reminder I have
Alpha 4 outer two set for R1 and R2
there's a good set of Woody it doesn't
matter to us which of these bolts you do
first but the bolts Will Spring out when
it's fully released you have the same
settings for both
ferns
happy that was eight turns
Steve and you can remove the Ard and
then we'll be torquing back this bolts
uh Sultan I'm ready for
okay Woody uh we're uh needed a few
minutes a few seconds to set up our
values here
is removed
happy Ard removed your settings are
brothel one clockwise two and you'll be
driving this stop block bolt to torque
oh
it's probably one clockwise too
is that set good settings
Bravo
one
last
hey what are you ready for uh the next
motion so it's going to be body and
meter and sexy centimeters oh that
sounds great you'll go for that motion
again
we are 48 minutes into today's space
walk and NASA astronaut Steve Bowen and
Woody hoberg are continuing to work
together to remove Bolts from the
International Space Station rollout
solar array in order to release it so
that it can be carried on the Canada arm
too
step through the next set of procedures
is
I'm going to hand it over to my
colleague Anna Schneider who's going to
step through the next set of procedures
with you
okay one meter to God continue
[Music]
all right Steve I copy 11 foot pounds in
a green light could you say turn count
again
[Music]
we're just checking on those turns Steve
if the bumper rolled on top of the mount
you may not get as many turns as you
might have expected okay so on stop
motion but you can look at it it's it's
on there nice and snug
we are in the public position and you
are go for a vaulting
it works
on there that sorting it's on the boat
it's on the amount it didn't go past
about
you see it
now you can see it NASA astronaut Woody
hoberg beginning to release the r bolts
all right Steve I'm sorry one more time
we're going to have to have you say what
you saw on those turns and whether you
counted the turns or you're reading them
off
well I counted the terms correctly
bumper the lock
but it turned it went on to the mount
for the bolts dancing
therefore it is locked in place
below bumper
and the feature both is clear
all right thanks for the clarification
again Steve this is a good bolt you can
store your PGT and we'll have you
translate to stanchion Charlie for the
Charlie one Ard
the bolts that hoberg is working on
um are on the boom end of the upper
irosa or International Space Station
roll out solar array the first two bolts
will allow the boom deployment system
rollers to be moved into place to help
with the array deployment later in the
spacewalk are you rotating the
deployment system
both sprung out hung out and it was 9
decimal five on R2
79 decimal five that is a good bolt
release Woody uh we need you to access
R3 and R4 next you can GCA if you need
to I have new settings for you and as a
reminder these will be the 245 turn
bolts so we need you in a good body
position
you just heard confirmation that Woody
hoberg successfully released two of the
bolts and he's moving on to the second
set
and Woody we are ready
okay so it's on half a meter station uh
correction half a meter volume down
and we caught the half a meter body down
okay stopping motion copy
good motion
you're hearing some conversation between
NASA astronaut Woody hoberg and UAE
astronaut Sultan alniadi who is inside
the space station operating the robotic
arm as he moves Woody hoberg down a
little bit to access the next set of
bolts
okay you can read about something else
complete
Steve once in position you can tether to
the Ard tether points and then I have
settings for you for the Stop block
and I'm ready for settings
Bravo 3 counter two ten turns only
three counter two
and Jenny I have Alpha
three clockwise three for R3
copy Alpha three for clockwise three
verify verify your PGT turn count to
zero
ready
copy PGT turn count is zero you can
release our three
copy
starting first
copy Woody
the second set of bolts that Woody
hillberg is currently working on will
release two of four mechanisms that hold
the ISS rollout solar array and it's
rolled up configuration
when folded the irosa measures
approximately 10 feet by two feet by
four feet
all right
eight terms
and
it's loose
[Music]
copy eight turns on the Ard you for it
on the stop block bolt is remove the Ard
let's remove the edges removed thank you
for settings to drive back in Bravo One
clockwise two
30 seconds from short Handover
well NASA astronaut Woody hoberg
continues to work on those bolts
NASA astronaut Steve Bowen continues to
work on the anti-rotation device
copy Steve you've driven the stop block
bolt 12.1 torque seven turns and a green
light
foreign
over 12.1 torque seven turns in a green
light you can Stow the ards in the crew
lock bag
over there
NASA astronaut Steve Bowen has released
both of the ards or anti-rotation
devices and will begin sewing them in
his crew lock bag
here on the screen we continue to see
National astronaut Woody hoberg work on
releasing the second set of bolts on the
boom end of the upper irosa
stop
all right here he's going in
and I think I pull out the uh
toolk or the uh traffic caddy a firm
Steve those are good good words
we need the 5 8 12 inch wobble on your
PGT and you can Stow the 7 16 on the
socket caddy
and I'll put that in work
in here
copy
Jenny 245 turns R3 turkey timer pops out
copy 245 turns on R3 with the turkey
timer passed out your settings are alpha
three counter three
for R4
Alpha three counter three SEC Euro
currency
here you go
starting
NASA astronaut Woody hoberg is currently
working on the last of the four bolts
these last two bolts release two or four
mechanisms that hold the irosa or ISS
roll out solar array and its rolled up
configuration
the 12 inch wobble
test on the instead of daddy
going for the 5 8 12 inch
Steve I copy a good pull test on the 7
16 12 inch on the socket caddy
all right football pass on me
follow that five days wobble for my TGT
all right and good pull test on the 5 8
inch 12 inch on your pet
Steve now we will be breaking torque on
the Arosa ffe bolt you can translate to
bolt Charlie one which is stanchion
Charlie should be right next to you
for only one right now
will be breaking torque on this bolt
less than half a turn
your settings are Bravo 3 counter two
good way yeah if I get myself into your
position
huh
Brothers three
counterclockwise
good words
correct a firm
and big picture for All crew we are
about a minute and a half
from
an loss we have voicecom for the first
five minutes and for the last five
minutes I'm still Prime IV
I will hand over to Frank when I need to
is that easy one copies that I had 45
more terms on C1
copy torque broken on C1 you can
translate to C2
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
245 turns and you see the turkey timer
you can work with Frank to move to the
carrier back off
you just heard confirmation that NASA
astronaut Woody hoberg finished
releasing the fourth bolts
that bolt was holding the irosa in its
rolled up configuration
security and this is basically the big
new body out one meter 60 centimeters
and that is stationed forward you also
heard them reference something called a
turkey timer that is basically just a
status indicator to ensure that the
bolts are fully released
we are now in a unexpected Handover that
will last about 15 minutes
we are currently about one hour and five
minutes into today's space walk
it began at 8 25 central time this
morning 9 25 a.m eastern time when the
spacesuit switched to battery power
Steve Bowen who is ev1 with the red
stripes egressed the crew lock and
received a crew lock bag and then ev2
who is Woody hoberg followed him shortly
after
Bowen then translated up the forward
face of the trust and went starboard
config configuring his safety tethers on
the way and then hoberg followed a
similar path but went to the port crew
equipment translation Aid or Cedar cart
to temporarily Stow his bag and retrieve
the articulating portable foot restraint
Bowen then translated to the irosa or
International Space Station roll out
solar array carrier stowed his bag and
retrieved the pistol grip tool
Bowen began preparing the irosa for
removal from the carrier first releasing
a restraint bolt on the upper irosa
meanwhile Woody hoberg relocated the
foot restraint and installed it on the
Space Station's robotic arm
from there Woody hoberg Ingress the foot
restraint and then at the arm moved him
away from the trust and towards the work
site
Bowen translated to the lower irosa and
released its first restraint bold and
then released both anti-rotation devices
on the upper irosa and stowed them in
the crew lock bag
while on the robotic arm Woody hoberg
was flown over to access two different
sets of bolts on the boom end of the
upper irosa the first two bolts allowed
the boom deployment system rollers to be
moved into place to help with the array
deployment later in the spacewalk and
then the second two bolts released two
of four mechanisms that hold dirosa in
its rolled up configuration
the goal of today's space walk is to
install an irosa or International Space
Station rollout solar array to augment
power generation for the 1A power
channel on the Space Station's starboard
Truss
the new solar arrays measure 60 feet
long by 20 feet wide once they're
deployed and shade a little more than
half of the original solar arrays which
are 112 feet long by 39 feet wide each
new irosa produces more than 20
kilowatts of electricity and once
installed will enable a 30 increase in
power production over the station's
current arrays
there's about six minutes left in this
15 minute loss of signal before we'll
return to scene Steve Bowen and Woody
hoberg working on today's spacewalk
once we're back we'll see uh Steve Bowen
working on releasing the upper irosa
restraint bolts and installing the first
two handling AIDS called scoops and
preparation for removing the irosa or
International Space Station roll out
solar array from the carrier
currently aboard the International Space
Station we have the Expedition 69 crew
which includes NASA astronauts Frank
Rubio who is inside the space station
helping with today's spacewalk also
inside the space station is UAE
astronaut Sultan al-niadi and Ross
Cosmos cosmonauts Sergey brucopia and
Dimitri patelan
and then of course our spacewalkers
today are NASA astronaut Steve Bowen and
Woody hoberg
here in the room we have the flight
director Diane Daly at the helm and she
goes by the call sign Horizon flight
and then serving as the prime ground IV
we have Ginny Gibbons
there's about one minute left in this
loss of signal and then we'll quickly
return to scene what Woody hoberg and
Steve Bowen are progressing
today's space walk is the 264th
spacewalk and supportive space station
assembly maintenance and upgrades and
the seventh spacewalk out of the space
station for this year
thank you
that's about 47 minutes to go
promotion
so during that loss of signal
um Steve Bowen released the upper irisa
restraint bolts and installed the first
two handling AIDS called Scoops in
preparation for removing the irosa from
the carrier
clear continue
you can now hear some discussion between
NASA astronaut Woody hoberg who is on
the Canada arm robotic 2 and UAE
astronaut Sultan al-niadi who is inside
the space station maneuvering the arm
how's that looking good if you want any
further GCA yep thanks yeah bye
could I please go body down
20 centimeters
they are flying Woody hoberg to the
hinge end of the upper irosa once there
both Woody hoberg and Steve Bowen will
work to remove the final bolts holding
it to the carrier and then Steve Bowen
will install a second scoop in Woody
hoberg will then lift it off of the
carrier
that's a great spot
see I complete
that was 15 centimeters body down
perfect
we copy GCA complete
would he attach a rut to the scoop which
is on irosa
okay James I have a rat on the scoop on
Irish much much time
puppy uh warning for both of you
Steve goat
they'll say I have the first group
from anywhere station it's a long
duration High down feather uh do I need
to bring the rat with that or did I
leave the rent it's transfer to 40
thread
DHS pull as well you can leave the rat
you'll stow it on your mini workstation
and uh Woody will use a rut from his
mini workstation in order to tether to
it
Okay so
we can get ahead on our checks here uh
so a warning
for both of you do not release C1 until
I give you the go
Bobby
I'll take a glove inspection and have
check from Woody
there's no change to the gloves
I'm just dry I can also report uh visor
down glove heaters on
tcv step
reference
copy good glove inspection and Hab check
cooling visor glove heaters are set
check gauntlets down
they're both down
check tools and tethers are clear and
your Ingress Aid is clear
control started Cutters and Embraces at
all clear
check heels secure in the apfr
yeah and James did you guys happen to
get eyes on my heels just for positive
confirmation there or can you see them
checking
Woody we do not have eyes on your feet
but Steve could potentially check what
you need
to take a picture
okay I'm feeling quite positive so I'm I
think it was pretty good
yeah I agree all right he oversecure
James thanks
Woody those are good checks we will
pause here
when I tried for
I am not transferring the adjustable to
what is just the scoop and the loud
version titled brother and I keep you
adjustable with me to pick them up later
correct
checking Steve
I think it's just a scoop and a long
duration I do too but I want to make
sure that's right Steve so there's no
requirement to take the adjustable with
you you can have it if you want but we
just need the scoop and the long
duration tie down tether bundled
together and the red swap to woodysburg
mini Workstation
okay I understand
and Woody if you have a rat I sure do
here's a rat I don't know if you can
reach me oh yeah you can send that over
here
I got several things on there right now
so okay
see it
the goals to get this right on the scoop
yeah okay it is on so okay that
adjustable then you got it
is coming back all right thank you very
much thank you all right let me get that
clipped on here
and I will get set up
copy we have a couple of additional
checks here as well we need a glove
inspection and half check from Steve and
a buddy check of each other's helmets
for signs of water
yeah
actually stay right there Steve okay I
have a good view into Steve's helmet
I can see what's happening
uh absorption band
and I see no signs of water
diapers
I'll put my advisor up for you
and I actually knows your helmets
absorption bad and that medication one
looks good great my gloves are the same
they're still good and my half is dry
copy we have good checks
and as a reminder Woody we track you
holding that scoop at this time it needs
to be Reddit to you but Steve needs to
be holding it he will be the one
installing it after C1 release
go to the
top hole for earlier
thank you yep we are now about one hour
and 27 minutes into today's space walk
before Woody hoberg and Steve Bowen
removed the final bolt holding the irosa
to the carrier they're performing a
series of glove and hop checks Eva you
are both doing great on time we are an
hour up
all right copy that
all right great James thanks
all right next as written I have uh
Steve releasing Charlie one fully Woody
you're going to maintain control of
irosa as he releases that bolt and
installs the scoop
okay Jan sounds good I've got irisa hey
I need settings
Bravo 3 counter three fully release C1
the bolt Will Spring out expect 26 turns
[Music]
try to clockwise three
they're about 26 turns and
spring out
all right that's starting right now good
words
you just heard the ground IV here in the
room Jenny Gibbons
um
to speak with the NASA astronauts
outside the space station Woody hober
again Steve Bowen
they were given the go to release the
irosa
so both crew members are now working to
remove the final bolts holding the irosa
to the carrier
Bowen will then install a second scoop
while hoberg lifts the irosa off of its
carrier
all right
guys
27 turns
to come off I think I need to start a
few more
but not three of this fold copy 27 turns
now that seems very loose I got an
initial
insurance
yeah I think it's uh it feels yeah quite
loose okay
let's go with EGP and get those that's
great
good words
all right I had the scoop locked on I
hope that's a good config Woody that's
great Steve I have irosa you're at iroso
Crown copies we agree we're in a good
config Steve we need you at the grapple
Tower to assist with this GCA make sure
I Rosa clears the fixed scrapple fixture
and I have cautions and a warning for
both of you when ready
all right I am in a good position to
watch clarison from the Orchestra
I'm ready for warnings
caution prior to removing irosa ensure
the FSE is not moving
Steve you stay still on the FSE during
the release and warning don't put your
fingers in or around any of the pin
slots mounted on the inside and outside
of the root beam
with that I will let you work together
to release irosa to do that Woody you
will be sliding irosa away from you to
release from the FSE pin slot interface
okay James I believe that has already
happened I think so too
happy I saw control of it we're looking
good all right
your go-to-workers here
all right Frank if you're ready
I'm ready for the eyebrowser back off
position I've got a good eye on the
tower
and I'm looking for this to go straight
and uh Woody uh it's drifting a little
bit toward the tower
going to fire sit a little back okay
that's probably good ready to go Fred
Steve will you copy and for this motion
we expect about four meters and for
Woody is going to be body down
okay
and we are stopping motion
you heard confirmation that NASA
astronaut Steve Bowen has installed the
second scoop onto the carrier and
Woody Bowen and Woody hoberg Has Lifted
it off of the carrier
there will now be several Maneuvers with
hoberg on the robotic arm
and then he will arrive at the 1A mod
kit work site
during these Maneuvers Steve Bowen will
pick up the temporarily stowed crew lock
bag from the port cart and reconfigure
both of his safety tethers on his way to
meet hobrook at the mod kid
we are clear continue
we have three meters to go
continue
Houston copies since we are clear of the
grapple Tower and this is a procedure to
publish position I'm going to pick up
com with Steve Steve perform a socket
swap I need the 5 8 12 inch wobble on
the socket caddy and the two inch from
your trash bag on your PGT
I understand the 5 8 is going to
the soccer caddy the two inch from my
trash bag coming on my PGT
good words I'll take full tests for
everything and then you will be cleaning
up the crew lock bag with everything
inside of it doors facing the FSE
from this view you can see NASA
astronaut Woody hoberg on attached to
the Space Station's robotic arm as he
moves away with the International Space
Station roll out solar array
and rambling out copy
okay that is the public position Woody
and just heads up our next motion is
going to be that Rosa pitch join of all
counts of two and a half minutes
first before I do my too much
thank you
I copy Steve
you have completed the pull test correct
that's correct that all three of the
sockets all the socket yeah that's
complete
copy again you can still that socket
caddy we'll have the crew lock bag
buttoned up with the doors facing the
FSE and the adjustable equipment tether
cinched
NASA astronaut Woody hoberg continues to
make his way on the robotic arm with the
irosa to the 1A mod kit worksite
okay it's on the outside of the 21 bags
I should have the needle nose
the wire tie and an adjustable
and then I need a small large small
adjustable attached to the lower hand
rail
and then this rat should come with me if
I'm being destroyed please
correct there should be no red on the
outside
that rat can go into the bag Steve
understand I'll just put it in the bag
on the left side of your screen you can
see the helmet camera of NASA astronaut
Steve Bowen he is currently working to
pick up the temporarily stowed crew lock
bag from the port cart and reconfigured
both of his safety tethers on his way to
meet Woody hoberg at the mod kit
once they both arrive at the mod kit
site both crew will then work to install
the irosa onto the 1A mounting bracket
and all the we are ready for the Arizona
pitch uh join ocas and we will give you
a countdown before we start and just
remember uh the uh pitch man over
come on that's perfect I'm ready
right then starting join AllCast in
three two one starting motion
okay since then
[Music]
thank you
copy Steve great work
once complete you can translate off of
the FSC via the POA
heading off the
just
foreign
we need that two inch on your PGT Steve
I get it when I saw okay that sounds
great you can do that at the mug kit
we'll pick up the bag
[Applause]
firm your first step once you are off of
the FSE is to retrieve your green Hook
from three zero one one
sure
thought you got that right there
the our next motion is going to be an
outboard Journal Castle three minutes
from that copy and I'm ready
ah
all right okay motion for the journal
cash for the evl code
I'm ready another countdown would be
great I'll be starting in three two one
currently on your screen you can see
NASA astronaut Woody hoberg as he is on
the Space Station's robotic arm moving
the International Space Station rollout
solar array to the 1A mod kit work site
all right
foreign
[Applause]
ah
today's space walk is the 264th
spacewalk in support of space station
assembly maintenance and upgrades and
the seventh spacewalk out of the
International Space Station for this
year
foreign
space Walkers are NASA astronauts Steve
Bowen and Woody hoberg they are working
to install an irosa or International
Space Station roll out solar array this
will augment the power generation for
the 1A powered channel on the station's
starboard truss structure
the new arrays once unfurled measure
approximately 60 feet in length by 20
feet wide and they shade a little more
than half of the original arrays
each new irosa will produce more than 20
kilowatts of electricity and once
installed will enable a 30 increase in
power production over the station's
current arrays
this spacewalk is the ninth spacewalk
for NASA astronaut Steve Bowen and the
first spacewalk for NASA astronaut Woody
hoberg
copy the two inches installed on your
PGT with a good pull test
ah
a
I just heads up with the next motion is
going to be an IA lineup for f4r and I'm
expecting three minutes so fun sounds
great I'm ready
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
all right cleanup is retrieved
copy Steve you have your green hook
after this you'll get the bag and
Woody's green hook
all right bringing up the bag
good words
okay with you we are ready to start the
motion and this will put you in lineup
uh position under the iea
all rightful time I'm ready
okay starting in three two one stop
emotions
promotion copy good morning
Stephen Woody will be an insulation in
about two minutes
Thanks James
foreign
we are now about 1 hour and 48 minutes
into today's space walk we are actually
about an hour ahead of the scheduled
timeline
once they arrive at the mod kit site
they will begin the process to install
the irosa onto the 1A mounting rocket
CRT
and releasing it from the uh
copy Steve
ah
all right
during the installation process for the
International Space Station rollout
solar array the crew will release the
scoops and Woody hoberg will then move
into position to release the final bolt
holding irosa into its folded position
once released Woody hoberg will hold
irosa closed
uh
once released Steve Bowen will hold
irosa closed while Woody hopeberg
egresses or exits his foot restraint and
gets into position both crew will then
work together to unfold irosa and secure
the right side onto the mounting bracket
once secured Woody hoberg will then
drive two hinge bolts that I that Iris
into the folded unfolded position
this one bag is throwed
full of tree equities
copy Steve Woody's green Hook is
around mile marker six three zero zero
six three zero zero
A-frame it'll be on
on three six zero exactly
head back that way
if you use green hook
what's up
copy
and Woody we are ready uh for you go for
the GCA to form the Shadows install
hold on I'm ready I see body left
as affirmative we are expecting a first
motion of body lift and it's going to be
2 meters 40 centimeters and Then
followed by a body up
and that is 70 centimeters
okay sounds great Sultan I'm ready
[Music]
on my right
feather
no I'm going to translate out
to
F4
copy Steve and I might have missed it
but I need to check that reels are
unlocked and your gauntlets are down
all right Wheels unlocked
are down
there's that much resolution copy like
you said you're headed to the S4 iea I
have words on where to attach Woody's
green Hook when you're ready
and only we are ready to start watching
body left in three two one on the big
loop for All crew do not start this next
motion stand by one will We sync up on
the ground
that was good motion Photon that whole
position now
more information for all of you on that
call everything is looking like it's in
good shape you guys are doing great on
the timeline we just since we are ahead
we want to hold and get all crew in
position that means means we'll have
time for Steve to drop the green Hooks
and get in a good position by the
mounting bracket before we go to the
install position from there we will push
with the procedure as written
thank you
both are what it is
great Steve thanks for doing all the
work while I just ride the arm
and Ivy group Ivy crew comes
all right great job everybody
ah
from this view you can see both
astronauts working on today's space walk
in the upper right hand side of your
screen you see NASA astronaut Steve
Bowen as he works to configure some
safety tethers and work his way over to
the mod kit site to meet Woody hoberg
and then a little bit further down is
NASA astronaut Woody hoberg aboard the
International Space Station's robotic
arm holding on to the International
Space Station roll out solar array or
irosa as he makes his way to the mod kit
site here
copy Steve
you're looking for handles
number for his screen two two one nine
number three two one
happy and you'll be fair leading Woody's
tether around the outside edge of the
iea
the outside edge of the iea for his
early
good words
let's see just for awareness I'm right
behind you and a little to the left
all right
your green Hook is now on p219
and I release my
each other
copy good words
and it looks clear of my tether
good words and confirm the Reel is
unlocked
and his real is
so you think you unlocked
good config Steve you can continue on
your translation path your next step is
to drop your green hook handrail 2218
heading down
foreign
[Music]
copy greenhook 2218 check your tethers
are clear and you'll go to continue
it looks great all right let's get to
here
for my uh absolutely
is that much of a view
uh
you might feather clear now
copy Steve I have a question
go ahead James
your caution is avoid translation on the
PVR handrail near 2230
Steve you'll continue your translation
to the left side of the mounting bracket
check your tether routing for snags and
crosses and place Fair leads such that
your tether is running around the
perimeter of the iea
okay let me get myself here
okay
almost to a fair lead on the corner I
guess
two three five
I have your fair lead handrail written
as two two four eight
but two three four two three five is
fine please it will do the same thing
okay
we'll be right in the same spot
copy that sounds good we are 45 seconds
from a short Handover
very translating up to the
whole Mountain
Steve and once you are in a good spot
uh you can resume this motion for the
irosa install position
all right let me drop my bag
oh there you are
I am
one second to get stable
foreign
[Music]
okay copy ready to continue Woody and
again this is going to be a continuation
of the body left and we'll give you a
countdown here in three two one starting
motion
promotion
Ally
you'll need two meters to go continue
we continue
foreign
but uh ready to start the body up motion
paper I'm ready for party up it's
starting in three two one
good motion
to go
okay continue
feels a little high actually I think I
feel a little high and a little short
you need to come toward me
another uh
40 centimeters
I see that Steve uh and you are still a
little high
yeah so Tom could I come
by checking you gotta take the scoop off
when you close yourself
actually this feels pretty good
full-time can we just go body in
20 centimeters
utility will give you that body end 20
centimeters starting motion and three
take your hands off too there you go
continue
okay stocking motion and three two one
motion I agree
you are hearing conversation between
NASA astronaut Woody hoberg and Sultan
alniadi who is a UAE astronaut inside
the space station operating the Space
Station's robotic arm
if I'm ready to take the scoop off but
the soft dots are set they've not been
cycled
a little bit ago Houston's back with you
we see that the soft captures are in a
good position we do not need to cycle
them
Steve Hold irosa Steady well Woody
removes the scoop and I have some
cautions and warnings I need to read
warning when you're on the app side of
the mod kit Steve avoid contacting the
Legacy blanket boxes and trunions
caution while you're both on the mod kit
don't simultaneously impart loads
sudden stops and quick grabs are not
allowed on the mod kit 30 pound Max
lateral load on the mod kit and finally
confirm no BGA motion prior to
installing our Rosa
copy all copy all sounds good James
thank you and Stephen Woody just to
confirm that you don't need any further
GCA and we'll call it complete
can you give me 20 centimeters
do you have enough of that oh yeah okay
don't agree
all right uh did you say complete and
brakes are coming on Happy brakes on
Houston copies breaks are on you can
work together for install
it just guess yep I agree
been real slow this way yep
moving my uh
perks here
okay for the push
for the mouth cancer
starting to get in
Afghanistan
by running up into something like
get eyes on it
both of our spacewalkers have made their
way to the 1A mod kit work site
for from here the crew will work
together to install the irosa or
International Space Station roll out
solar array onto the 1A mounting bracket
we are in the floss we are just waiting
to continue to the left
how does the soft rock look on your side
they're still popped out do they just
need to be pushed down no it should be
fine come right through
all right if you can still come by
toward the mouse canister that's all we
need
uh and run it up against something when
I try to push that direction okay
did you push your side I'll hold on
let me just look at it real quick okay
Steve your hecka might be contacting hi
Rose I'm preventing the soft duck you
might have to adjust your body position
oh I understand
okay working on that
never say that Woody
pushing hard left
and it's just out of the soft dot Fork
you know what I think we need to pull up
on the softbox
maybe to let it fast
and get that
oh yeah that's
the problem all right let me get the
other one okay I think I'm in on my side
um
that's good Steve okay my side's in soft
top or soft capture Channel and in front
is not in I don't think it's really
close
uh you might be in the defense so try
popping it out of the little defense
yeah turn it a little upside down in
let me look
I think it's just the inmate little lift
that holds the tin
I think we're in the right position with
irosa
and you're okay
yep
try me into your La uh right yeah
all right they try and get down here
there you go nice 20 seconds to a short
Handover
[Applause]
s
yeah
it needs to turn
um
fog lights from above clockwise from
above other other way otherwise yep now
we should go in
we are in a brief but expected Handover
period we'll receive camera views from
the space station in about 10 seconds
do this
they're trying to get her better
Houston's back with you how to get there
okay so Jenny just to describe what
we're seeing we believe I Rose is in a
good position
um the center of most
okay
yeah we agree we have a really good view
from your hecka Woody so good job at
this point uh Arosa is soft dog so you
can release your red from the scoop and
maneuver to the R6 back off
Steve for you you're finalizing the
config for the crew lock bag and you
will eventually receive the scoop bundle
from Woody when he's ready
any chance you can uh
pass me a threat
when you get a chance
thank you
for both of you are we're we are just
over two hours into an Eva tracking for
seven hours and 30 minutes limiting
consumable is battery on Woody and you
guys are still about an hour ahead on
the timeline well done
perfect drills
okay if now's not a good time we can
wait
a little
um well here can you reach this
oh yeah that might work
you're coming at you
crew is now working to release the
scoops
and then Woody hoberg will move into
position to release the final bolt
holding Iris in its folded position
let us know what you need
that sounds great I'll be uh oh actually
oh I bet I can just do that
let me take a look at that
if you have the position here go away
okay
Bravo 2 counter two
yeah
this coupon uh
long duration
yeah you should have two scoops there
Steve okay you ready to get your right
back I'll give it to you let me know
when you yeah go ahead
better jobs
got it Uber yep I got it all right
[Applause]
Steve once you tempster these uh scoops
and the long duration they can just be
temp still for now but that's up to you
at the crew lock bag we'll need you to
position to hold I Rosa in a folded
config while Woody does this bolt and
that he Cress this apfr
let me get the bag in place and then
I'll be
pretty much set to do that how about two
counter accused fat jams copy those are
good settings you'll be releasing R6
the bolt Will Spring out when fully
released you'll see a white line
indicator expect 18 to 20 turns
you want me to wait yeah because I'm not
in a place
I got you
I'm in a great place to control it
better speed
all right well if you want to stay there
then that's fine I just gotta put this
bag in place and clean up
that's great
foreign
and we got the white line visible
is released
copy R6 released
line you can store your PTT
complete
and uh Frank and Sultan for your
awareness
I suspect my plan will be to hop out of
the arm here eventually
in order to a copy
all right at the back of the handrail
and the streets to the bag right
Gatsby's and
get the bag off my vrp
okay
hey Steve
do those Scoops go in the bag eventually
yeah okay gotcha
future that'll be around the time when
you retrieve the AMS knob it's just crew
preference you can sew them for now if
you want
for you and uh for Steve and Woody um we
copy Woody that you think you can egress
from here that's no problem with us and
we're coordinating with Robo And The Ivy
team
Steve we see you getting in position to
hold I Rosa folded we'll need you to
we'll need you to do that well Woody
egress is using only the Ingress Aid
all right let me get my hand on the
other hand rail okay
yeah take your time Steve just watch
your helmet is uh close hitting the
other side of that roast there yeah let
me get my feet up though
NASA astronauts Woody hoberg and Steve
Bowen just worked to release the final
bolt holding irosa or the ISS rollout
solar array in its folded position
from here Steve Bowen will continue to
hold irosa closed while Woody hoberg
egresses or exits his foot restraint and
gets into position
after that the crew will work together
to unfold irosa and secure the right
side onto the mounting bracket
oh
okay I think I think everybody around
here
all right what do you think I'm good
okay just so you know your hacker is
like touching aerosa but as long as
you're not pressuring it should be yep
looks like it just lights so yeah should
be a good config all right you've got it
I have it okay for your awareness we see
that contact it's on the root beam and
ground's fine with it so you two are
doing a great job Woody you can egress
using only the Ingress Aid
foreign my feet are out
copy you can check the Ingress Aid is
low profile
actually that is going to be interesting
let's see
to get on the expansion you might have
GTA just because I might need a GCA just
to throw the Ingress in unfortunately
yeah
take a look here real quick
and we will be copy and we stand in life
okay thanks so proud actually I got it
appreciate it
Crown copies off
from this view you can see that Woody
hoberg has egressed the foot restraint
from the robotic arm
all right
if I am in a
C
get my eyes on this soft dock
yeah I'm in a good position do you want
to cycle it yeah
to make sure it's free
I just got I want to think about my
safety tether so
NASA astronaut Woody hoberg is now
moving into position uh to unfold irosa
to help secure it to the right side of
the mounting bracket alongside NASA
astronaut Steve Bowen
move to that position yeah we might need
that as soon as this clear we can open
this yep I agree with that
is that making sense to you guys too
Woody and Steve we've been talking about
the arm position and your tether here on
the ground and we think it's best if we
maneuver to the tether swap position
the last two jams we like it
all right you can initiate that way and
Steve you can initiate that with M1 once
you do that since that's a published
position I have some big picture words
for you because we need to pause anyway
before you put in a fair lead Woody but
you can go ahead and coordinate with M1
for now
okay great sorry we're ready for you to
move to the published
other swap position
okay Woody we coffee yeah this will take
us uh three Maneuvers to get to that
position and uh we'll let you know when
we're there all right sounds great
Photon I'll be watching while the arms
near us
I thought we'll be starting with uh the
backup position and we're expecting
about two meters uh like anybody with
body right
okay yeah body right looks correct that
sounds great
okay brakes are coming off
Woody and Steve were just getting those
big picture words together for you we
have another couple minutes and then
I'll have them
thanks Jeff
to get clear
all right I have to restart the motion
now go
I have those big picture words for you
let's let M1 start the next motion and
then I'll pass them
all right I understand m1's already
maneuvering to the backup position so
you guys ready
yep good motion ready
all right big picture you are doing
great
um we have a really good timeline laid
out in front of us so good in fact that
there is a potential that the next
eclipse could be our working eclipse for
our cable mates that's in around 25
minutes so we might break out of bolts
and take that opportunity while we have
it and I'll keep you both up to date on
that there is no rush because again our
nominally planned Eclipse was the
following one
um how copy
ev2 copies that sounds great yes it does
all right good
next piece of information I have for you
is that we have noticed that a grounding
pin is out of place on the mod kit
it's at the base of the mounting bracket
where the mounting bracket meets the
left lower struts
after the unfold we're going to have to
address that grounding pin it should be
no problem but I will let you know and
I'll give you those words again when the
time is right
and just to be clear that's on Steve's
side and we don't want him to check it
now
I'm not going anywhere I can't let go
we agree please keep hanging on
all right
it's hard to beat them light
those are all the big picture words that
I have for both of you we will pick up
after these Robo Maneuvers with a fair
lead for Woody and then
start to work toward unfolding irosa
your warning is that this is a pinch
point and you'll need to keep clear of
rotating eye Rosa
where's your family that's right there
I was wondering that's you
because you might be able to head that
way and then when you get to the lower
just drop it
your fairlead is going to be on the
right lower strut lower hand rail Woody
right lower strut lower hand rail got it
that means what's really having a good
assessments when this will be clear then
and Woody you need to hold the reason
why we're waiting is because we cannot
put this fair lead in while the arm's
moving
I understand James I was just checking
out the location thank you all right no
problem
okay well yes dear we are starting our
next motion is going to be a journal
cast and it will be two and a half
minutes
motion
what do you take some pictures of our
dragon
that's a good idea standby
we are about two hours and 27 minutes
into today's space walk as NASA
astronaut Steve Bowen and Woody hoberg
continue to install the International
Space Station roll out solar array onto
the 1A starboard Truss
they are about an hour ahead on their
scheduled timeline
and now targeting a working Eclipse
about 21 minutes from now for the cable
meeting
take a selfie you'll get the whole
I think it's like a station
the cable meeting is when both of the
crew members will work to electrically
connect the new irosa to the
International Space Station's power
system
they'll first attach four connectors to
irosa and then both will move to either
side of the Legacy solar array to
disconnect the old array and connect a y
cable this will allow power to flow from
both the new irosa and the old Legacy
array to the Space Station's power
system
uh
Woody when able power on your heka it's
been powered off again
the green light that's good complete
Champs thanks
copy all thank you
what is the arm even moving the market
yeah I can tell I think there's said
enough for the drug test okay
and uh Woody we are starting our next
join our class it'll last three minutes
and then we'll stick up with you and uh
it's gonna be
um step in here to meet with you and for
the tell us one okay continue so fun
we're ready okay starting motion for the
general caps
emotion
from this view you can see NASA
astronaut Woody hoberg near the irosa or
International Space Station rollout
solar array and the robotic arm is
currently backing away
see Jenny if I happen to have a cat
Keeper in my hand would it be a good to
remove the J1 through j4 caps
you can do that Woody
okay copy thanks
on the other side of the folded irosa is
NASA astronaut Steve Bowen
Steve Bowen is continuing to hold the
iro set closed
oh yes
what's that the good hook a good release
thanks Steve
you are you are seeing the helmet camera
of NASA astronaut Woody hoberg as he
configures some of his safety tethers
once his safety tethers are reconfigured
the crew members will work together to
unfold irosa or the International Space
Station roll out solar array and secure
the right side onto the mounting bracket
hey firm
L4 curler
I agree
I just grabbed the AMS knob while I've
got it before I get right here
Houston Guppies
yeah let me look at that stand back
and us now it's ready to my midi
Workstation
okay
and J1 cj4 caps removed Journey they're
in crew lock back again
we copy Woody
foreign
right
there should be available for that for
that
was the one that you loved yep
yep here it is
all right
about the adjustable external
I don't think we needed external okay
let's put that in the bag okay do we
need the external for the adjustable
we're going to use that later on to grab
anything else
crew lock back on
no we won't need that you can Stow that
inside the bag
okay
so both of your awareness couple more
minutes here
um and then we'll be able to get moving
again do a good job getting a little bit
ahead on the grill perfect
ah
body I'm not sure if you hear the area
call but uh we are set up and ready for
manova to tell us proposition
okay sounds great photon
you are Joe
okay copy go
since this is a published position Woody
you also have an option of assisting
closing keeping irosa in a closed
configuration so stopping it from
unfolding while Woody or well Steve
excuse me addresses that loose grounding
pin
that sounds like a great idea James let
me get in position and then you can do
exactly that
I just need to push on that Friday so
I was talking emotionally enough copy
full time
okay Steve
all right enjoy
I can burn my arms again
we're glad to hear it Steve you should
be able to see a little uh receiving
area for the pen it should be near where
the pin is loose you just need to
reinstall it
all right heading down to the base of
Fitbit trucks
this is the strut
you should not have to translate far
Steve you should be in a good spot to
see it
is at the base of the mounting bracket
itself where where it meets the
elections
or at least the left strip
yeah so I see
these two turns here
another one yep there is another one
that is not installed
yes the second one that you touched is
not in so we need you to reinstall that
before here
that's right thanks Steve
all right give you one second
oh
all right take that thing good tools ah
all right great job Steve we are good to
continue with the procedure we
understand the arm is in a uh its final
position so Steve we need you to hold
irosa in a closed configuration and
Woody you can place that for your lead
all right give me one sec employees
all right thanks for the break what do
you guys got it now
copy you've got it
thank you
big picture call for All crew we are
headed into a region of spottycom
followed by an loss that total time is
six minutes your go to continue with
irosa unfold
Frank we are in Block nine
step 26 27. Frank you are prime IV
a firm once you have completed with the
unfold we will have you move to the
cable mate block that is block 10.
with the Space Station's robotic arm
backed away and in a safe configuration
the crew will now proceed with unfolding
the irosa
good words
we are in a brief but expected Handover
period and we'll get views of the space
station back shortly
the first working eclipse is about three
and a half minutes away from now and
that is the first targeted window to
mate the cables
so after they unfold the iro so they
will move ahead to that step
okay now it's starting to clear your
future Keys you're almost there there
you go you're clear
thanks
barely even installed let me just take a
quick look at my feathers absolutely and
then we'll get into air unfold
sure
one more thing to fix and then I'll be
ready Steve
Frank this is ground we're coming up on
that Los when you get there we will need
you to confirm safing for the working
eclipse
and Jenny we probably we will need to
confirm a safety and that'll be two
minutes
foreign
okay guys uh this is going to be a
warning for you both there's a pinch
point so keep clear of the rotating eye
Rosa
has to be verified that uh or would he
verify that you've cycled the right soft
capture feature
I'll go ahead and do that right now
okay thanks buddy and then just uh make
sure that you leave it in the soft
capture feature down position
s
okay and
then keeping in mind the pinch Point
Steve go ahead and slowly pivot I
roaster to unfolded Woody engage the
right side alignment guys
you can hear conversation between NASA
astronaut Frank Rubio who is on board
the space station and currently serving
as the prime IV or communication link
between the space walkers
all right nice job guys and so Woody
then go ahead and verify the soft
capture feature is properly engaged
so I have control and we're still
rotating thanks Frank
today's space Walkers are NASA astronaut
Steve Bowen and Woody hoberg and they
are currently working to unfold the
irosa or International Space Station
rollout solar array
once it is unfolded they will verify
soft capture is properly engaged and
then they will perform some glove
inspections and hop checks before moving
on to Cable meeting
okay great job guys I need you both to
perform a glove hap and Gauntlet check
and then it will start moving towards
our cable mating positions
great Frank ev1 has no change to gloves
dry hop and gauntlets down yep I agree
DB1 does that sorry EBT
the first working Eclipse window has
started and there's about 30 minutes for
them to complete the cable mating
process
[Music]
in there Frank
copy that the job guys just to let you
know at this point the hardware meets
minimum structural config for mating
cables
actually yeah so why don't we until we
get into that it's over here
all right so all right we have the caps
for
the nvtl Caps we're ready to demate
those on your go
okay you can uh teammate the mdgl Caps
from P1 P2 P3 and P4
it works
easy and Ivy crew Houston our last
little bit of calm here we can confirm
our spacing is in place and we are in
our Eclipse condition so you are go for
the eclipse required cables
you guys have a Time or when a window
ends
you have 28 minutes
we'll be back with you by then and as an
additional reminder you'll need to
complete the nset GLS before you move to
the eclipse required cables
everybody like you okay
caps now
these are pretty sticky yeah
okay guys once you have the Caps off not
even close friends you're going to be
meeting yeah
the Caps off
both Woody hoberg and Steve Bowen are
now working to electrically connect the
new irosa or ISS rollout Solar Ray to
the Space Station's power system
can be a bear
okay I think I got one
that's a trick got the lever I still
don't have the camera
okay got one
ah
as they work through the cable meeting
process they'll first attach four
connectors to the irosa and then both of
them will move to either side of the
Legacy array to disconnect the old array
and connect a y cable this will allow
power to flow from both the new irosa
and the old Legacy array to the Space
Station's power system
we're about 2 hours and 53 minutes into
today's space walk and we are about six
minutes away from getting signal back
from the space station
today's spacewalk officially started at
8 25 a.m Central Time 9 25 a.m eastern
time when the spacewalkers switched
their spacesuits to battery power
Steve Bowen who is ev1 with red stripes
egressed the crew lock first and
received a crew lock bag and put it on
his body or straight tether he was Then
followed shortly by ev2 or Woody hoberg
who is in the unmarked suit
they then translated up the forward face
of the trusts and went starboard
Steve Bowen stopped to configure his
safety tethers and then Woody hoberg
followed a similar path going to the
port crew equipment translation Aid cart
and retrieved and articulating portable
foot restraint
Bowen then translated to The irosa
Courier and retrieved his pistol grip
tool and began preparing irosa for
removal from the carrier
hoberg installed the foot restraint on
the Space Station's robotic arm Ingress
the restraint and then the arm moved him
away from the truss
both Bowen and hoberg then worked to
release a series of bolts both restraint
bolts and anti-rotation devices
once those bolts were released they
installed the first of two handling AIDS
called Scoops in preparation for
removing irosa from the carrier
once they installed the second scoop
hoberg lifted the iris off of its
carrier and then after several Maneuvers
on the robotic arm he arrived at the 1A
mod kit work site during these robotic
arm Maneuvers Bowen worked to make his
way over to the mod kit site
where they met to install the irosa onto
the 1A mounting bracket
more recently the crew unfolded the
irosa and are now working to mate the
cables
once the crew members finish connect
electrically connecting the new iros of
the Space Station's power system they
will work to drive some hinge bolts
these these bolts will help to fully
secure eye roasted to the mounting
bracket before unfurling it
here in the room we have flight director
Diane Daly who you can see in the middle
of your screen and next to her is the
prime ground IV Ginny Gibbons
also in the room we have our Eva Flight
controller who is Megan shudica today
good words ready and please you're going
to be disconnecting saw copper seven
from the panel top of seven and saw
up a two one from panel pop it through
one all right
Houston's back with you with a
correction
okay
probably
a chance all right great job you guys we
had some spotty shot SS there so we
could hear you you did a great job we
just want to confirm you're doing each
cable one at a time I don't mind which
one you start with just tell me which
one you're going to start with but only
demate one cable from the panel at a
time
okay
ready to go
Woody I'm ready bye
all right I'm gonna do p21 first okay
Frank you ready for me to take back over
copycams you are prime
got it I'm Prime IV great job all right
I copy you're already disconnected
that's p21 disconnected from panel p21
I agree that is true
all right mate p21 Alpha to panel p21 I
need fraud pins Emi check and the
connector needs to be to hard stop
okay
Alpha is in my hand
s
I'm standing by Jim
Woody you have a go to continue we just
need one cable on each side at the time
clarification for you so tell me if you
want to start with P9 or p23
okay I've got panel t9d mating
here you go that's demated
mate P9 Alpha to panel P9 I need fod
pins Emi check and the connector to hard
stop
copy jams
okay
P9 Alpha
Channel denied
no Ben 10 notified good Emi band
checks your go
at all right p21 Alpha is made to p21
panel
that was pretty in my band no thoughts
good pins
copy good mate Steve confirm the
connector is to hard stop
and the connectors to hard stop
great work you can move on to
j21 Alpha made it to saw cable p21
James I have P9
the panel hardstop
copy that's a good mate Woody you can
move on to j9 Alpha made a two saw cable
P9
Alpha
cable P9
I have no bent pins no fod
Mi band all right I have
a woody 221
j21 Alpha
we have good pins no pod and good Emi
band and that's connected
copy Steve that is a good mate you can
move on to disconnecting saw cable p7
from panel p7
p7
I'm sure
you can now see live views of NASA
astronaut Steve Bowen working to mate
and demate some cables on the irosa
okay James property nine to j9 Alpha
connector sorry uh it's not connect your
heart stop
ready for panel p23 good words Woody
move on to disconnecting saw cable p23
from panel p23
you made it no Ben tents
all right
whatever you made it
open pins no thoughts
installing j7 p7 Alpha
copy Steve and copy your checks a firm
mate p7 Alpha to panel p7
uh dance I have p23 Alpha
beta to panel q23 so far though that
bend Stadium I did
stop
hey firm
connect j23 Alpha to saw cable p23
car cable p23 to j23 Alpha novented so
far good Emi band
inside connect your hearts up
copy Woody that is a good mate and I
track that that is your last connection
for this side verify the connector
config is as expected and clean up the
remaining cable slack as required
okay that's gonna work thanks James
and Woody we were tracking that your
hand did touch a connector p24 we just
want to make sure that that is still too
hard stop
good catch and I
uh do our correct removed if it is back
at heart stop
and I'm going to check pizza
I can confirm all four panel connector
and
copy Woody we agree
foreign
Steve you're both doing great we have
over 12 minutes left of this working
eclipse
ah
James I think the cables on the right
side are looking to be in a good
condition
that one wire size located
great job
Steve uh you can move on copy to hard
stop you can move on to connecting j7
Alpha to soft cable p7
and that didn't work
Woody we agree your work site is in a
good config we will have a glove
inspection Hab check and Gauntlet check
for you before you translate to R7 and
8.
NASA astronaut Steve Bowen is currently
working to connect the last cable
once it is connected he will verify that
all the connection connectors are
configured as expected and clean up any
remaining cable Slack
are
delicious
Hey Kevin Alpha made it to p7 so then
ten no five and two are hard stop
copy excellent work Steve that is a good
mate you can verify that your connector
config is as expected and clean up any
remaining cable Slack
all right I see oh look
what's the hardstock
and
not sure how bad this is do you want
this flush against the
um
checking
I think it looks not too bad
we're taking a look and it looks like
you're in a good config Steve we're
happy with that
jams no change to gloves IHOP
copy witty and you cut out there did you
say gauntlets down
that looks down
copy good checks from Woody
all right okay
Woody you can translate to the hinge
bolts
[Applause]
caution for you Woody
you should avoid contact with the cables
and NZ GL connectors which are now
attached to irosa I Know It's tricky at
this work site you can hold on to the
bolt canisters that are on either side
of the essential connectors
okay great yet I see those you can copy
all jams
Steve again we're happy with your work
site this is the end of our Eclipse
requirements for this uh Eva so great
work to both of you I need a glove
inspection half check and Gauntlet check
from Steve
okay let me fly out past the Staples
back there though
all of the cables have been successfully
connected this will now allow power to
flow from both the new irosa and the old
Legacy array to the Space Station's
power system
s
settings
Alpha One clockwise two
thank you
Steve your job at this time is to
provide extra stability to Woody because
he might not have much to hold on to
when he drives these bolts
yeah hi copy Steve uh tell me if you
need it let me see how we're doing here
yeah
Alpha One clockwise two is set
good settings Drive the hinge bolts 14
to 17 turns to heart stop
14.
NASA astronaut Woody hoberg is now
working to drive two hinge bolts into
iroso while it's in the unfolded
position the crew will then work
together to drive eight bolts to fully
secure eye roasted to the mounting
bracket
because I got 17 and a half turns green
light
do decimal four foot pounds on R7
copy R7 17 and a half turns green light
to decimal four on the torque
okay
driving R8 here we go
Woody hoberg is now driving the second
of the two hinge bolts and then Steve
Bowen will work to drive the eight bolts
to fully secure iro Stitch the mounting
bracket
the kitty just confirmed once that's
complete Steve Bowen will move to a
deployment viewing position and Woody
hoberg will release the final two bolts
holding irosa in an undeployed position
and then irosa will deploy over the next
six to ten minutes
17 decibels to five turns
and two decimal three foot pounds green
light
17 decimal 2 5 turns two decimal three
on the torque and a green light that is
a good R8 we have a go for you to use
the AMS knob as a Delta to the procedure
as requested so at this time you can
store your PGT and we will have you
loosen each hinge bolt one turn and then
finger tight less than one turn on R7
and R8
okay James I understand all work
Woody after this is complete or excuse
me Steve after this is complete you will
be stowing the AMS knob in the crew lock
bag
got it right here Steve let's get a rep
for you
I'll hand it to you there you go
ahead
thanks
all right chance
R7 R8 finger type
copy Woody we are happy with that uh
your next step is to complete your
tether swap so we will have you
translate back inboard to the arm you
might have to GCA from the tether swap
position if it's required I'll let you
work with Frank and Sultan for that
Steve you are going to drive m-bolts on
the bottom of the mounting bracket
all right let me install the very best
knob and then I'll
ready to do that
and James I copy all I'll be picking up
my fair lead and going back for cutter
swap
good words
keeper
copy Steve
for Steve and Woody okay there's no
preferred order on the end bolts correct
no preferred order you can start with
which whichever one you want first let
me know when you want settings
and Steve for your awareness we are
tracking the m34 had one turn hand
started on it if you started any other
bolt just let us know
all right and so the first one
is M21
is that correct
underneath the uh
after I started that here
as well with one turn
and jams I started a few as well so
Steve can call them out the one let's
see which ones they are yeah okay that
works well for us I copy the M31 already
has one turn on it Steve your settings
are Bravo five clockwise two
level five clockwise
[Music]
oh
shall pass
good life
and 39.9 volts
and here you got the settings again
Jenny
Bravo 5 clockwise two
the Bravo five
clockwise
you'll be driving these bolts such that
the black line is flush it'll be to
torque it's like the 11 to 14 turns
that's 11 14 turns left
good words
for both of you we are three hours and
20 minutes into this Eva tracking a time
of 7 hours and 30 minutes
limiting consumable is Woody's battery
and we are around 45 minutes ahead of
timeline great job
hi I'm 31.
NASA astronaut Steve Bowen who is eb1
today is currently working to drive the
eight bolts to fully secure irosa to the
mounting bracket
torque of 22 seven turns green light and
was that a black line flesh call
and there's a black line
for these
so
Sam's Mike Green reel is locked to my
red reel
picking up my yellow hook
copy that'll end up on your green reel
locked I'll take your checks
you are currently seeing views from NASA
astronaut woody woody hoberg's helmet
cam he is working to swap some tethers
okay and I think my next thing is to
reposition apfr to clocking six
good words
he's now about to start working on
repositioning the articulating portable
foot restraint on the robotic arm
meanwhile NASA astronaut Steve Bowen
continues to work on driving the final
eight bolts
all right
looks like M32 33 and 34 all hands dirty
we copied
and verifying settings
Bravo 5 clockwise too
good words
copy M32 drive until Blackline flush to
torque
stands for apfr
go
right repositioned talking six
papa papa six which now can to be
depressed good pulled fist Fest
followers black on black
and it Ingress is low profile
be good install Woody you can give M1
and go for the iea back off and we will
have you translate back to the mounting
bracket
all right
11.31 turns and torque of 21.1
or M31 in M32
copy that is a good bolt for M32 you can
move on to m33
that didn't work
you're seeing live views of Steve Bowen
working to drive the final eight bolts
he is currently on the third of eight
each others have been removed from there
and the ffr reconfigured and ready to
head over to the park position bricks
are coming off
behind you right
all right I got a great green light
got the 11.4 turns 21 44 foot pounds
arms 43.
copy Steve's that's a good bolt for m33
we'll have you move on to the next one
all right m34 is gonna work
copy m34
all right a good green lights
um
and Steve I copy green light and that
bolt is driven but I need you to read
back the torque and the turns you cut
out
23.0 turns into the 11.5
you know the arm is starting motion
filter
copy that's a good bolt Steve
all right
you can move on
okay copy M35 has not been hand started
you have the same settings
NASA astronaut Steve Bowen is now
halfway through installing the eight
mounting bracket bolts he has four to go
and has completed four of them
meanwhile NASA astronaut Woody hoberg is
currently translating over to the
mounting bracket
back of the green light
the sun is my eyes
and 22.0 for pounds
is it useful for me to socket Swap and
help Drive these or you want you to
stick my PPT
otherwise
yeah absolutely I can do that we're okay
with you doing that but Steve say again
the number of turns frame 35.
12 points
copy 12.2 that is a good bolt then if
you transfer your PGT to Woody we can
drive the remaining bolts we're looking
for M36 through 38.
I should be Bravo five
let me pass it back under here okay
I got it
okay
except just got to get in position no
that's fine
and Stephen or the arm would be in
motion
results on
okay
NASA astronaut Steve Bowen just handed
off the Pistol Group grip tool to Woody
hoberg who's going to help him drive the
final three bolts
all right
see what we got
yeah they got
26 decimal two nine turns green light 21
decimal 9 foot pounds
you must have gone back out that's
trouble
we'll subtract the terminal okay
we're just checking on that Bolt
by my memory that's uh
14 turns and a great green light and big
torque it's a good bolt we can move on
that was M36 we're ready to move on to
37 and 38.
437 yeah
it's been a good spot okay let me Circle
this out because I bumped it
okay
Bravo
five o'clockwise two or seven good
settings
all right
foreign
twenty
correction 12 decimal five turns green
light 21 decimal 9 foot pounds
good bolts you can move on to M38
NASA astronaut Woody hoberg is now
working to drive the final of the eight
bolts to fully secure the International
Space Station rollout solar array to the
mounting bracket
after that's complete ev1 or Steve Bowen
will move to a deployment viewing
position while ev2 who is Woody hoberg
will release the final two bolts holding
irosa in an undeployed position
trying to find a position where I'm not
sideloading
we copy
congratulations
a little bit
we're good I'll see you
okay I'm 38. we had 11 decimal nine
three turns green light 22 decimal two
foot pounds
there you go Steve
put my hands off here
we copy Woody uh that is a good bolt we
just needed the confirmation the black
line is flush because we cannot see it
in Eureka
yes black line flush trying to point out
it
copy great work we are complete with our
M bolts uh Steve you can Stow your PGT
and we'll have you positioned to observe
the first five magnets snapped together
when we deploy
uh Woody you need to get in position on
the base of the mounting bracket for R9
and r10
okay getting in position for R9 r10
and I'm getting a position to watch
deeper good words Woody as a reminder
this is a Bravo 7 setting you can use
the scoop on the base of the mounting
bracket to brace yourself
I don't see that thank you
foreign
Steve agree you're in a good position
Woody I see your PGT out warning for
both of you prior to releasing the
deployment launch for straightfolds
positioned to stay clear of deploying
our rows of blankets you will both be in
a good position
foreign
Bravo 7 counter two and I'll have you
hold here Woody
okay copy that Bravo 7 counter two is
set all right we're in a good position
good words
NASA astronaut Woody hoberg is standing
by to release the final two bolts
holding the ISS rollout solar array in
an undeployed position you are going to
release R9 and r10 the white line will
appear when they are fully released
expect 17 to 20 turns irosa will deploy
after the second bolt is released
ah
radar copy starting with R9
once the these final two bolts are
released the irosa will deploy over the
next six to ten minutes
falling off the at the station here
copy we understand that looks great
line visible I counted 17 turns on R9
copy 17 turns on R9 stand continue to
stand by Woody
the first of two restraint bolts has
been fully released
up a little bit
foreign
ah
Steve as long as as long as you can see
we'll be comfortable with it Tech is
desired but your eyes are enough for us
happy
foreign
all right great work Steve if you are in
a stable position we're happy with your
view Woody you are going to release r10
s
[Music]
and turns down
30 seconds to a shorthandover
I count 20 turns so far
I'm gonna continue
you might have to wiggle it Woody
gotcha
the second of the two restraint bolts
has been fully released and irosa will
begin to point over the next six to ten
minutes
short hand over
we are now in a brief but expected
Handover period and will regain signal
of those beautiful views of the space
station in about 10 seconds
thank you
all right Houston's back with you
welcome back
Woody you are staying exactly where you
are well done on the final bolt to
release irosa and Steve will take your
report
looks like it's stretching out nicely
and everything seems to be lining up
what to do did you have a good view now
copy we don't have video back yet but we
will shortly we appreciate the words
all right I'll stand by
we have our video back everything is
looking great I have two cautions for
you Woody
you can now see live views of the
International Space Station rollout
solar array as it begins to unfurl as
the space station flies over the coast
of the Southwest United States
sounds good to us
everything's looking really good to us
again well done you too Woody again you
have to stay put but Steve you can get
moving if you want to we're still well
ahead of schedule so you can stay and
look a little longer if you prefer it
but your next step is to pick up your
green hook
all right
come here
copy
Woody if we can we'd love to adjust your
heck of you a little bit if you could
pitch back at all for us we'd appreciate
it
thank you
foreign
Woody hoberg is continuing to monitor
the irosa as it deploys meanwhile Steve
Bowen is translating back to the irosa
carrier to reconfigure the carrier beams
that previously held the upright iosa
these beams will need to be rotated out
of the way to allow access to the lower
irisa which will be installed on next
week's Eva on June 15th
ah
all right we're going to read real
that's complete
copy Steve
sounds great
once fully deployed the irosa or
International Space Station rollout
solar array will measure 60 feet long by
20 feet wide and will shade a little
more than half of the original array
each new iroso will produce more than 20
kilowatts of electricity and once
installed will enable a 30 increase in
power production over the station over
the station's current arrays
hopefully those came out we'll see
yeah
copies
Steve whenever you're ready you're
headed to the FSE
w
copy
I have more questions and warnings for
you when you're ready
to clear this
be ready
let me know
all right I'm ready for coffee
Steve
warning and a reminder grapple shafts
and perfect coupling are no touch zones
no sudden movements quick grabs on the
FSE wait until motion dampens out before
imparting loads on the FSC
don't simultaneously impart those into
the FSE this is for when Woody is also
ready to translate and do not contact
the arrowser blankets
foreign
space station rollout solar array or
irosa continues to pull it to deploy on
the starboard Fortress connected to the
1A power channel of the space station as
the space station flies over South
Dakota
I do not have a fair lead listed for you
Steve and no green hook drop let me just
confirm
yeah I can confirm that now Steve there
is no action for a fairlead or green
hook drop you are just translating
directly onto the FSE from the port
Cedar cart so do not take the POA path
than last time
probably get you there Jenny
I think we first both are C7 C8 correct
hey firm that's right you're going to be
at stanchion Alpha and this is a Bravo 7
setting so you might need to get in a
better brace position
copy let me know when you're ready for
settings
that works
Woody we are nearly complete more words
for you in a minute
okay thank you
apparently the setting for c738
Bravo 7 counter two
level seven
good read back you'll be releasing C7
and C8
expect 8 to 11 turns
it's 11 turns
378 good words
uh Here Comes two steps
hey James it looks to me like motion is
fact yep we're just double checking that
we can confirm a good deploy Woody what
would help us is if you could confirm
the bottom five magnets on both booms we
don't need a heck of you we just need
you to see that the magnets have snapped
together
1.5 and C7 is popped out
copy C7 released you would go for C8
sometimes I'm thinking I might need to
move to see this do you agree with that
or am I missing something
magnets
hey Farm Woody you will have to move in
your go to translate right now
right now you're seeing views of NASA
astronaut Steve Bowen as he works to
release the beam restraint bolts he has
already released one of them and has a
couple more to go
copy C8 is released Steve Stow your PGT
and translate to stanchion Bravo
translation
ah
a
Steve a Delta tier plan will have you
continue translation past expansion
Bravo to stanchion Charlie because we
have enough time for a small efficiency
here
okay don't tell us
yeah I do see that first five magnets on
the right side engaged
copy Woody that sounds good
left side I see it as well
copy thank you Woody with that we can
release the blanket tensioner bolts our
11 and R12 on the ISS inboard side of
irosa
okay 11 and 12. Alpha One
alpha alpha one counter two a successful
deployment of the International Space
Station roll out solar array or irosa
has been confirmed as the space station
flies over Quebec Canada
thank you
NASA astronaut Woody hoberg is now
working to release blanket tensioner
bolts
after he releases these two bolts it
will allow the irosa blankets to become
tensioned
good settings
starting with R11
copy R11
meanwhile NASA astronaut Steve Bowen is
working on a get ahead task to release
some additional beam restraint bolts
okay and it's Francis Bravo what would
you like
retrieve the pit pin from the stowage
location push the C1 bolt into the can
and install that pit pin
firm you should be at stanchion Charlie
Bravo
thank you
since I got five turns on R11 it pops
out with a white band
and I saw the tension on the array
puppy five turns are 11 released
you can move on to R12
start insurance
about four turns on R12 I saw the
attention
got the good White Band at the bottom of
our 12.
copy our 12 fully released you can store
your PGT and verify all the mli on the
line on the mod kit is in place we want
no metal struts or collar bolts showing
NASA astronaut Woody hoberg just
released both of the tensioner bolts
that allowed the irisa blankets to
become tensioned he's now going to work
work on cleaning up the mod kit work
site
we're checking Woody thanks for the go
back
the pit pen has been solved entirely one
copy Steve your next step is to release
Charlie 4 and Charlie three so two
initial beam additional beam bolts this
is a Bravo 7 setting so I'll let you get
in position
all right give me a second
all right Woody I can confirm that we
are happy with
foreign
and R12 so we need you to verify all the
mli on the log kit is in place
that's in work right
side is looking good
copyright side Bravo
seven
o'clockwise two
a firm Bravo 7 counter 2 you will be
releasing these bolts expect 8 to 11
turns
for
copy Charlie four
all right Charlie Ford's done
but uh
copy Charlie Charlie four is released I
need you to repeat the turn count
ER
copy you can continue on to Charlie
three
reasons
looking good I'm eating up a couple
spots
and I'm ready to retrieve the scoop
s
NASA astronaut Steve Bowen is now
working to release the second of two uh
beam restraint bolts in his get ahead
task happy Charlie three released Steve
you can Stow your PGT and we'll have you
translate distancion Bravo
Woody power your hecka on
right and Woody we are happy with the
mli current config and we do not need a
heck of scan so you're exactly right you
can remove the square Scoop from the
mounting bracket along with the
adjustable tethers and sew it in the
crew lock bag you can close up this crew
lock bag and stow it on your brt
I'll be all in work
and we do not need a crew lock bag
inventory lucky
oh thank you so much
ah
thank you Bravo
copy Steve you will be retrieving the
pit pin from the stowage location and
stowing the C2 Bolt
I accept them Charlie too
good words
installed
copy pit pen installed on charlie2
we need you to connect a Rhett
to the adjustable equipment tether
d-ring from
d-ring to the beam handrail stanchion
understand get my adjustable ready to
catch the fish okay that'll be at work
okay copy
thank you
ah
all right just to be clear is ready you
want
the rats
attached to me or just something else
there should be a wret to an adjustable
equipment tethered d-ring and not
adjustable equipment tether hook should
be on the closest beam handrail
stanchion to you
so you have an adjustable attached to
the beam and the d-ring attached to a
red and that red is on your mini
Workstation
that's what I needed to hear okay we'll
get our adjustable
one hook going to
expansion
figure
all my other adjustable
copy Steve we're gonna have you hold
here we're gonna get Steve's on the SSC
with you and then we will move forward
with our beam release
all right we're waiting already sounds
good
yeah we will have you get yourself
all right well have you get your PCT out
we're not releasing any bolts yet again
we're waiting
um
to do that but this will be a Bravo 7
setting to release Charlie 5 and Charlie
six so you can get ready for that you
have some time
Woody yeah
I was about to tell you your next step
is to press the starboard seated cart
break release
and then you will be
translating to the Port City cart
all right you got it
while you're translating Woody I have
big picture words for both of you
if you want to see the cart
foreign
you can get both we I just confirmed you
need one of the two on both Cedar cards
just took us a minute
okay thanks
in the starboard side copy
Woody you are going to be dropping your
green hook on S3 handrail 3011
and then stowing crew lock bag M on
three two one seven
three two one seven okay thanks James
good read back let me know when you're
ready for those big pictures
okay we are now four hours into this
seven hour thirty minute Eva limiting
consumable has not changed that is the
battery on Woody and we are still one
hour ahead of timeline obviously we've
deployed our Rosa so great job to you
both
we are getting
um to the point where we are going to
Stow the FSE beams and remove that fod
if we have time we're going to do some
get aheads and release the ards for the
next Eva
that sounds real good thanks James
okay I found three zero one one that was
my green hook location correct hey firm
and then three two one seven for the bag
got it
go ahead
foreign
copy ensure you go via the POA path fair
lead on MBS handrail 8400
copy that a firm yeah I'm looking for it
right now you're seeing views from NASA
astronaut Woody hoberg's helmet camera
he is working to translate over to the
carrier beam where NASA astronaut Steve
Bowen is currently
once they're both over there the crew
members will work together to release
the bolts holding the beams in place and
then they will rotate them out of the
way and secure them back down
the spacewalkers continue to remain
about an hour ahead of schedule
after they release the beam there's a
couple of get ahead tasks that they can
work on prior to Ingress
all right am I heading to Alpha
so Steve and my Charters will
that should be up there
all right Alpha
ah
Woody your next step is to perform a
socket swap Steve was able to already
release C3 and C4 so we'll just take the
socket Swap and then move on to rotating
the beam
okay
now I will need a socket caddy to do
this correct
they only have oh no
a firm you're going to use your pit pen
you'll remove the six inch wobble from
your PGT and sew it in your trash bag
with the pit pin and the two inch that's
currently I believe in your trash bag
will be stowed on the PGT
release one of the C5 or C6
hey firm Steve you can release either
one Bravo 7 counter two at your settings
good words
foreign
copy 11 turns and that was C6
copy will hold here
I agree
okay Jenny I've got the 5 8 2 inch rigid
on the PGT
okay
so when Steve releases this final bolt
C5 uh
Steve you will rotate the Zenith end of
the beam toward Woody
and you'll be temp stowing the beam in
the stowage location which is parallel
to the blankets with the handrails
facing the POA you'll need two
adjustable equipment tethers to do this
okay and what do you have an adjustable
[Applause]
we'll be ready to go
all right we are go when you are ready
copy C5
but I just went
boy boy
retrieving my adjustable
NASA astronaut Steve Bowen just released
the final beam restraint bolts
Steve Bowen and Woody hoberg will now
work together
to rotate the beams out of the way and
secure them back down
install
disregard sorry these carrier beams were
being reconfigured they previously held
the upright erosa and they needed to be
rotated out of the way to allow access
to the lower irisa which will be
installed on next week's Eva Eva on June
15th
okay
I've got to adjustable on it I can cinch
this side we won't stick it down but
when you get yours on there we come back
we'll send it down Nicholas milk
that's correct
and this is going to
zero zero one two
copy and Steve's exactly right we'll
cinch this down later on what we need to
make sure of right now is that the beam
is clear of the Nader upper support beam
so that's the one by you Woody
it's clear
that I have no interference there
copy
Steve you can release your rat I
understand that the beam is Tethered via
two adjustables
all right
caution for both of you
copy a caution for both of you now that
this beam is tied down do not exceed 30
foot pounds on the temptoad beam and
again a reminder for the FSE we don't
want to simultaneously impart loads into
it so we will alternate if we need to
translate around the same time
selfie
we are in another brief but expected
Handover period and we'll regain signal
shortly
Houston's back with you after a short
Handover
we will need Woody to translate to
stanchion Delta and Steve will need to
translate to stanchion Charlie but again
please alternate your translations
okay what are you ready to go I am ready
to go okay go ahead and tell me when
you're there okay going to Delta
good words Woody once you're there
you'll attach a mini workstation Rhett
to the closest beam handrail stanchion
all right I'm at Delta putting that mini
workstation
Brett in work ah I guess set my
translation
copy both sounds great Steve
maybe we're fishing rod is down
Woody once you have that ret down you'll
be ready in your PGT
ails
all right Woody
what will be my uh PCT setting when this
room's over here
that was for Woody then you're setting
as Bravo 7 counter two
Bravo seven counter two is set so when
it gets here what will it be
the 23rd it'll also be Bravo 7.
you'll just be clockwise too
for Steve
okay finish that
all right I'm ready to drive C9
copy you're releasing C9 expect eight to
eleven turns
copy and work
I mean I counted nine and a half and it
popped out
ready for C10
copy C9 released your go for C10 about a
minute until a short Handover
are you starting during C10
10 popped out nine times
copy nine turns C10 popped out
you'll be rotating the beam toward Steve
copy
ready yep coming at you
I got it probably you got it
[Music]
32 about one turn you'll get two
back copy therefore I'm good
a little twenty right yeah I recall
Bravo 7 clockwise two
for no more than twenty no more than 20.
Houston's back with you
Houston's back with you I copy your
hands
I concur Bravo 7 clockwise 2. and this
will be approximately 20 turns
GPS but we are going to stop
[Music]
hey firm let's do 20 20 turns only
copy
ing C9
copy C9
and I'm stopping there it's pretty close
to the bottom
I got uh
15 turns plus the two to 50 at 19 turns
is that okay
checking
B9 I got
I put in 18 turns plus two hand starts
copy 18
for checking
Steve we want more turns on your bolts
let's hit it again at the same settings
how many more do you want
only one turn
all right that's it
complete
our 21st 41 yeah 23rd
puppy Steve stand by we're still
discussing
nothing we're still discussing that
config on the ground we might have more
action here Woody your bolt is good
thanks Champs
all right Steve because we took out on
this bolt we need to back it out one
turn your settings are Bravo 7.
did not torque out on this bowl got a
low torque okay we misunderstood then I
got 18.
you can see I have a red light for dark
featuring torque
hey uh Steve wait one I'm trying to get
a word from Houston here today uh I
think we came up on our handle real
quicker than I expected hey this is
Houston we hit a patch of Ratty calm we
are good on that bolt Steve so at this
time I'm handing over to Frank Frank you
are prime IV we are one minute away from
a five minute Los
foreign
block 12.
block 12 pick up in Step 32 for Woody
and 37 for Steve and Nick passed you the
additional instructions
all right Steve I'm retrieved my red
because that beam is installed
sure
assault
if you're on one so it looks like
NASA astronaut Steve Bowen and Woody
hoberg have successfully uh finished
rotating the carrier beams out of the
way and secured them back down
this was the last planned task in the
this Eva but they will now move into
some get ahead tasks for next week's Eva
thank you uh incidental block smudges on
my glove fingertips otherwise no change
and dry hats
okay I copy for both of you and you'll
just have to be a little bit patient
with me here because we're working now
out of a Jedi message and so I'll just
have to be talking back and forth on a
computer
we are now in an approximately five
minute loss of signal we will regain
signal shortly after that
during this period NASA astronaut Frank
Rubio aboard the International Space
Station is the prime IV for the space
walking crew
a couple of the get ahead tasks that the
crew will be working on include
releasing the Ard or anti-rotation
device for next week's irosa as well as
releasing some of the lower our bolts or
restraint bolts
while today's space walk has focused on
installing the irocerer or International
Space Station roll out solar array on
the starboard Fortress connected to the
1A power channel on the space station
next week's spacewalk will focus on
installing the irosa to the starboard
six truss connected to the 1B power
Channel
coverage of next week's spacewalk which
is U.S spacewalk 88 is scheduled to
begin at approximately 8 20 a.m Central
Time 9 20 a.m Eastern Time on June 15th
the spacewalk next week is scheduled to
begin at approximately 8 20 a.m Central
Time 9 20 a.m eastern time with NASA TV
coverage beginning at 6 45 a.m Central
Time 7 45 a.m Eastern Time